THE ASSEMBLY LESSONS COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR JUNE THIRTIETH. THE
BEFORE PERCY THIS CALL THE ROLL
MYSELF REFORM. BERMAN HERE
BERMAN HERE SAY AUTO HERE SEE
OUR TOWN HERE PLANET PLANET
HERE LOW. MAYES MULLIN BLANCA
RUBIO THANK RUBIO WAS HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM GREAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE DON'T HAVE ANY
AUTHORS IN THE INITIAL OFFER
THAT WE THOUGHT WAS GOING TO BE
HERE AT NINE IS RUNNING LATE SO
IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER AUTHORS
THAT WANT TO GET HERE TO
PRESENT THEIR BILLS. AND CAR
BAY DM. SEIZE THE DAY NOW IS
YOUR TIME- DO THE COVER
PANDEMIC WE CONTINUE TO OPERATE
WITH MODIFY COMMITTEE
PROCEDURES THE SOME OF THOSE
PROCEDURES HAVE CHANGED SINCE
THE COMMITTEES LAST HEARING
NOTABLY THE ASSEMBLY IS NO
LONGER REQUIRING SOCIAL
DISTANCING COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOMS WE ARE HOWEVER CONTINUING
TO REQUIRE THE ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS PRESENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM. MUST WEAR A MASK OVER
YOUR MOUTH AND NOSE AT ALL
TIMES WE ALSO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS FOR
THE PUBLIC TO TESTIFY IN THE
COMMITTEE INCLUDING ALLOWING
TESTIMONY AT A REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL ON ALONG TO
SOMEBODY BY PHONE. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF HEARING
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN
OUR TIME LIMITS WE WILL NOT
TOLERATE CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
COMMITTEE'S PROCEEDINGS.
DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR. OR
BEHAVIOR THAT INCITES OR
THREATENS VIOLENCE INCLUDING
VEILED THREATS IS PROHIBITED
PLEASE BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS
OF THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT YU
TO REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS THE COMMITTEE HAS SEVEN
BILLS ON ITS AGENDA TODAY THE
SELEUCUS SIX BILLS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE COMMITTEE IS ABLE TO
COMPLETE ITS BUSINESS IN THE A
LOT OF TIME WE ARE LIMITING
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS FOLLOWS A
FOR EACH BILL. THERE WILL BE A
MAXIMUM OF TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT INTO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WITH A LIMIT OF TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS AFTER WE'VE HEARD FROM
THE PRIMARY WITNESS THE PUBLIC
WILL HAD WITNESSES THE PUBLIC
WILL HAVE A TO FIFTEEN MINUTES
IN TOTAL TIME FOR ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT ON EACH BILL
STARTING WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WERE HERE IN THE ROOM.
THESE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME
OF THE ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENT IF ANY AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS WILL BE RULED OUT OF
ORDER I DID NOT MAKE A DECISION
TO IMPOSE HIS TIME WAS LIGHTLY
HOWEVER GIVEN THE LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME AVAILABLE FOR
THE COMMITTEES HEARINGS IT IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S TIME FOR APPROPRIATE
CONSIDERATION OF THE BILLS IN
OUR JURISDICTION IF YOU'RE
UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON THE-PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THIS
WRITTEN TESTIMONY WILL BECOME
PART OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF
THE BILL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING THIS HEARING REMOTELY
INTO WHICH TO CALL AND TO
REGISTER THEIR POSITION THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN AGAIN IT'S THE
NUMBER THE PHONE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FOUR WE SHOULD BE THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ONTHE
ASSEMBLY AUCTIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
OR COMPUTER SCREEN IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2094 AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY
TO. THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO THE AGENDA I HAVE ONE LAST
ANNOUNCEMENT TO MAKE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. SB FIVE EIGHTY
THREE BY SENATOR NEWMAN HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
TODAY AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR. WITH ALL THOSE
ANNOUNCEMENTS OF THE WAY WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE COMMITTEE'S
AGENDA AS SOON AS WE GET. A
SENATOR. SO IT SENATORS IF
YOU'RE OUT THERE. COME ON DOWN
CENTER STAFF IF YOU'RE
LISTENING GO FIND YOUR SENATOR-
NOT I APPRECIATED THANK YOU MS
RUBIO. I HEAR CENTER BAKER IS
ON THE WAY- HERE. THE BLINDERS.
SANDER CABALLERO BEAT EVERYBODY
I APPRECIATE IT IS RUBIO. AND
THAT IS PERFECT TIMING. AND SO
WE WILL MOVE WE WILL WITH THE
LAST IS FIRST WE'RE GONNA JIM
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
SEVEN FOURTEEN BY SENDER
CABALLERO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU SO MUCH- GOOD MORNING
SURE BERMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM PLEASED 2% SB
SEVEN FOURTEEN WHICH WOULD
AMEND THE ELECTIONS CODE TO
ALLOW ASPIRING CITIZENS SUCH AS
DREAMERS TO BE ELECTED TO A
COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE WITHIN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE WORK AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE IMMENSE OF
PROPOSED ON PAGES FIVE AND SIX
OF THE ANALYSIS SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN HOPES CALIFORNIA LEAD
THE WAY TO A MORE INCLUSIVE
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM BY CREATING A
PATHWAY FOR INSPIRING CITIZENS
TO RUN FOR MEMBERSHIPS TO A
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AS LONG AS THEY MEET
ALL OTHER ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AS OPPOSED BY CODE
AND SENT CENTRAL COMMITTEE
BYLAWS CALIFORNIA HAS OFTEN.
CHAMPIONED IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
LEGISLATION AND INITIATIVES
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT
IMMIGRANTS ARE PART OF THE VERY
FABRIC THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA
ONE OF THE LEADING WORLD
ECONOMIES WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT DIVERSITY MAKES US A
BETTER SOCIETY SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN REMOVES A SYSTEMATIC
BARRIER THAT KEEPS IMMIGRANT
LEADERS FROM A SEAT AT THE
TABLE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CURRENTLY THE ELECTIONS CODE
PROVIDES THAT A PERSON MUST BE
REGISTERED WITH THE PARTY IN
ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
APPOINTMENT OR ELECTION TO A
CENTRAL COMMITTEE. A PERSON
DOES IS BY REGISTERING TO VOTE
AND ASSIGNING A PARTY
PREFERENCE THIS IS EXCLUDES
DREAMERS WHO CANNOT REGISTER TO
VOTE AND THEREFORE CANNOT RUN
FOR ELECTION TO BECOME A MEMBER
OF THE CENTRAL COMMITTEE I
BELIEVE OUR DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM
IS STRENGTHENED WHEN EVERYONE
PARTICIPATES INCLUDING DREAMERS
WHO HAVE LIVED THE MAJORITY OF
THEIR LIVES IN THE UNITED
STATES THESE YOUNG PEOPLE CAME
TO OUR COUNTRIES AS BABIES ARE
YOUNG CHILDREN WITH THE
PARENTS. AND ARE PRODUCTIVE
MARANT MEMBERS OF OUR STATE
THEY ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE IN
THE WORKFORCE AND ADVANCE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL CAREERS AND OUR
COMMUNITY LEADERS IN THEIR OWN
RIGHT AND ESTIMATED. TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DREAMERS LIVE
INCALIFORNIA AMONG OTHER
COUNTLESS IMMIGRANT LEADERS
THAT CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE
COMMUNITIES AND WANT TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION AND
MEANINGFUL INCLUSION.
IMMIGRANTS WHO COME TO THIS
COME COUNTRY COME WITH THE
DREAM OF PROVIDING A BIT BETTER
FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES AND FOR
THEIR FAMILIES. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO
CREATE BETTER AND THRIVING
COMMUNITIES WHEN EVERYONE'S
VOICE IS RECOGNIZED AND COUNTY
COUNTED. SB SEVEN FOURTEEN ONE
INSURER THAT IMMIGRANTS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO A SEAT AT THE
TABLE AND COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE TO REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS. THIS
BILL IS A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
LATINO CAUCUS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WAS ENDORSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
ME. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT TODAY AND HELP WITH
FACILITATE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS IS CARLOS I'VE
GOT A HOST CHAIR OF THE CHICANO
LATINO CAUCUS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. SPONSORED SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU SENATOR
WILL NOW MOVE ON- TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AS A REMINDER EACH
PRIMARY WITNESS HAS A MAXIMUM
OF TWO MINUTES. AND MR AKULA. I
BELIEVE WILL BE TESTIFYING BY
TELEPHONE IF THE LINE IS OPEN.
THIS TIME WE DO NOT THE STOCK
WAS ON THE CALL. I'M SORRY. I
GET THAT DOUBTING IT IS NOT
DOUBTING IT- MAYBE W'LL GET
STARTED WITH WITH OTHER
WITNESSES AND HOPEFULLY I'LL
GET A CHANCE TO DIAL IN AND
WHEN HE DOES PLEASE LET ME KNOW
AND I'LL MAKE SURE THAT MR
AKULA AS TWO MINUTES TO TESTIFY.
SO WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THERE ARE NONE. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVEN FOURTEEN. OUR MOTION
GOT A SECOND. AS A REMINDER THE
PUBLIC WILL HAVE FIFTEEN
MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR
NAME. THE ORGANIZATION THAT
THEY REPRESENT IF ANY IN A
POSITION ON THE BILL. EXCEPT
FOR MR AKULA- WHO WILL GET TWO
MINUTES WILL START IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
PROVIDE THE POSITION ON SB.
SEVEN FOURTEEN PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TRISTEN BROWN ONE OF THE CO
LEAD SHARES OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY LEGISLATION
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE-
RESOLUTION AND LEGISLATION
SHARE OF THE CHICANO LATINO
CAUCUS. OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. HERE IN SUPPORT URGING
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN I BET
THOSE TITLES ARE HARD TO FIT ON
A BUSINESS CARD. THANK YOU SIR.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION I'M KIND OF MIXING
THINGS UP AS A RIGHT I DON'T
SEE ANY- LET'S GO TO- WITNESSES
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
TO PROVIDE THEIR POSITION ON SB.
SEVEN FOURTEEN. GOT A BLANK
SCREEN OTHER WITNESSES MONIES
ASIAN. SO LET'S NOW OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
THE POSITION ON SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. SEVEN
FOURTEEN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN ONE FOUR IF PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
OUR FIRST COMMENT APPLYING
NUMBER TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STE. LET'S MOVE ON. WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS EVELYN CAN
WITH VOICES FOR PROGRESS WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN LINE AT
THIS TIME. HEY WILL SLOWLY
BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO
GIVE THE PRIMARY WITNESS A
CHANCE THIS IS THANK YOU FOR
COMING FIRST ALL OF THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENED. THEY WEREN'T
EXPECTING TO BE ON AT NINE
FIFTEEN WHO WAS. FOX EIGHT
PERFECT. HOME ANY QUESTIONS ANY
COMMENTS- SEEING NONE. PLEASE
LET MR ALL BECAUSE I KNOW HIS
TESTIMONY WAS SO PERSUASIVE-
THAT THE BILL SAILED THROUGH
AND HE BROKE THE TIMER- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR CABALLERO I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS. THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT INSPIRING CITIZENS HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RUN AND
DEMOCRATIC COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE ELECTIONS IF
PERMITTED BY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WHILE ALSO ENSURING THAT
THIS PROCESS IS WORKABLE FOR
THE ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO
CONDUCT THOSE ELECTIONS AND FOR
COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEES. WITH
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS I AM HAPPY TO
RECOMMEND SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE. CALL
THE VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN HI. BERMAN I SAY ARCHER.
C. R. CHAU NOT VOTING BENNETT
SAY. BENNETT I LOW. MAYES MAYES
I MULLIN. BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA
RUBIO I. THAT THE BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOUR
MISS APPRECIATED THANK YOU. AND
I SEE CENTER BAKER IN THE CROWD
THANK YOU CENTER BETTER FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING YOU
HAVE TO BILLS ON THE AGENDA- SB
FIVE OH THREE IN FIVE OH FOUR
I'M IMPRESSED YOU ACTUALLY GOT
THEM- NUMBERED IN ORDER. WILL
PRESENT YOU ALSOWITH FIVE OR
THREE YET SOUNDS GOOD PERFECT
LET'S DO IT. ALL RIGHT. NOT TO
VOTE MASS VERY APPROPRIATE FOR-
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR PRIOR
TO BE HERE FOR THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE FIRST TIME. FIVE A
THREE IS ALL ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
INCREASING COMMUNICATION WITH
VOTERS BETTER DATA AND
CODIFYING WHAT WE KNOW WORKS
FROM THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION. CALIFORNIA'S LIKE TO
VOTE FROM HOME THANKS FOR YOUR
HELP AND ALL THAT DAN ARE VOTE
BY MAIL THIS CONFLICT 60% TO
ALMOST EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT.
BUT PRIOR NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY DO NO CLEAR STATEWIDE
STANDARDS FOR EVALUATING
SIGNATURES. BUT WHEN YOU'RE
GHOSTING FOR LAW STUDENTS
IDENTIFIED SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY AND HOW THEY EVALUATE
SIGNATURES. I NOTIFIED A CURE
CHALLENGE MAIL ABOUT. THIS
LITTLE STANDING THE NUMBER
REJECTED MAIL ABOUT SURPASSED
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND IN THE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY A PRIMARY
LOAN. THIS BILL SHORTS
ACCOUNTED TO CROSS STATE ARE
USING THE SAME UNIFORM
PRACTICES FOR SIGNATURE
ASSESSMENT AND REPORTING
REJECTIONS. CHAU SIGNATURES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT THE
MOST VIABLE CALIFORNIANS THOSE
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
DISABILITIES FIRST TIME AGING.
VOTERS AND VOTERS OF COLOR. SB
FIVE WITH THE BIGGEST
CONFIDENCE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
THAT VALID VOTES ARE IN FACT
COUNTED. THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE ON TOP OF THREE
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER. SO
LET'S MOVE ON TO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AS A REMINDER EACH PRIMER
WITNESS HAS A MAXIMUM OF TWO
MINUTES. I BELIEVE YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS FOR THIS BILL AS ERIC
HARRIS WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IS TESTIFYING. BY
PHONE- THE OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR MISTER HARRIS. MR
HATCHER LANCE OPENED. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING- CHAIRED MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ERIC HARRIS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE OH THREE THIS BILL SETS
OUT COMMONSENSE REQUIREMENTS
FOR SIGNATURE VERIFICATION
BETTER GOOD FOR ALL BOATERS AND
CODIFIED. BEST PRACTICES IN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE CURRENT
REGULATIONS FOR COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS ARE COMPARING
SIGNATURES MOTOR DISABILITIES
ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE THEIR
SIGNATURES REJECTED DUE TO
MISMATCH DO DISPATCHES WORKS
WITH THE ABILITY TO HAVE
SIGNATURE. BUT CHANGE OVER TIME
OR STRUGGLE TO CREATE A
SEEMINGLY IDENTICAL SIGNATURE
THIS BILL FABLESS CHIP THAT
IMPACT. MATCHES NOT REQUIRED.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
REVIEWERS USE THEIR REGULAR.
BEING THE BIGGEST- BUDGET
OVERALL ARE VERY GOOD HAVE THAT
INTEREST AND MINE BOTH THAT CAN
THANK BE- COME ON THE
REGULATIONS AND ARE VERY
PLEASED WITH THE OVERALL OUT.
IS REGULATION BLOCKING OF THE
VIEWERS TO DELAY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT WHETHER DISABILITY HAS
BEEN THE VOTERS. AND OTHER
FACTORS BLANK CHECK IS IN. THE
BILL AS PART BY THE GREAT WORK
OF STAMP AND YEAH- THE BILL ALL
CREATES NEW REQUIRED WOULD AND-
HOW AND WHY BALLOTS PROJECT.
THIS WILL ALLOW TO BETTER TRACK
OF THE BILL THE POSSIBLE
SIGNATURE REJECTION IS. FOR
VOTERS THIS BILL AND THINKING
TO IMPROVE BALLOT MUCH ACTION
OVERALL BUT IS GOOD BROUGH AT
THE- AND- THE VOTING FOR ALL
THE VOTING FOR ALL VOTE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER HARRISAND
NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION OF
WHICH THERE ARE NONE- SO WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO A-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB FIVE OH THREE
AS A REMINDER THE PUBLIC ALL OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME
FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
ALL ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
REPRESENT IF ANY. IN A POSITION
ON THE BILL WILL START IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
PROVIDE THEIR POSITION ON SB
FIVE OH THREE. SEEING NONE. WE
WILL NOW. MOVE TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION FOR ANYBODY
TO PROVIDE THE POSITION ON SB
FIVE OH THREE. SEEING NONE WE
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO PROVIDE THEIR POSITION
ON SB FIVE OH THREE. LESS IN
THIS EITHER IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION. TO SB. FIVE OH
THREE. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE ZERO
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
THERE ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
NUMBER OF FIRST LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE
NUMBERS MULLIN- SAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE OH THREE. THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE OF THE CAT
ARBITRATE A LINE NUMBER FOR THE
NEXT COMING.
LOOK AT THAT. GOT
A MOTION BUDGET FOR THE TWENTY
ONE MOMENT PLEASE NO WORDS
THANK YOU GOT A SECOND ALL
RIGHT. OUR NEXT HOW MUCH IS
FROM LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS KIM
ALEXANDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
VOTER FOUNDATION THANK TO
ENDORSE ERIC HARRIS OF COMMENTS
AND APPARTENANT A BACKER FOR
INTRODUCING SB. FIVE OH THREE
WHICH WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME GREAT SO
BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE
HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND
MISTER BENNETT. I APPRECIATE
THAT SENATOR BAKER APPRECIATE
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN CONCERNED TO AFTER
BEING INVOLVED IN SOME
DISPUTES- IN OUR COUNTY YEAH
WE'RE I WAS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR. WITH THE DEGREE OF
DISCRETION THAT WAS BEING USED
AND IT DEPENDED ON THE PERSON
AND THEIR JUDGMENT THAT. AND
ALL OF THAT SO I APPRECIATE
THIS MY QUESTION FOR YOU IS. IN
THAT STANFORD STUDY WITH ABLE
TO IDENTIFY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
BALLOTS WERE WERE VIEW- DEEM TO
BE- HAVE AN APPROPRIATE
SIGNATURES. DID ANYBODY DO ANY
FOLLOW UP TO FIND OUT WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE WERE
ACTUALLY SENT IN BY THE A VALID
VOTER IF THEY JUST SIMPLY TO.
MAKE. THEIR SIGNATURE MATCH
WHAT WAS ON FILE. OF THE HIGH
THOUSAND I DON'T HAVE THAT IN
FRONT OF ME- AND- DO THINK OUR
PRIDE WE HAD SOME OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE- PREVIOUS
HEARING FROM STANFORD I THINK I
CAN GET YOU THAT INFORMATION.
THAT THAT WAS REJECTED IN
TOTAL- NOT JUST OF THOSE
SPECIFICALLY IN THE SIGNATURE
BUT IT'S STILL IT'S QUITE
WHY THEY WENT. AND THEY FOUND
OUT THAT EACH COUNTY. WAS DOING
IT IN A VERY DIFFERENT WAY SO
THAT'S WHEN THEY START WORKING
WITH THEN. ASSERTIVE STATE
PATEA AND TO TRY TO
STANDARDIZE- BUT I DON'T HAVE
THAT EXACT SEVEN I CAN GET THAT
FOR YOU AFTER WITH
STANDARDIZATION SHOULD INCREASE
EVERYBODY'S CONFIDENCE EXACTLY
WHEN THE RESULTS AND SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SIR THANK YOU
FOR. THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SAYING NONE. CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
AFTER ASK RIVAL. ARE RIGHT.
WITH THE PRICE 90% OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS ALREADY
RECEIVING A BALLOT IN THE MAIL
IT'S IMPERATIVE WE HAVE UNIFORM
STATEWIDE SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION RULES AND
GUIDELINES. THIS BILL REFINED
THE PROCESS FOR VOTERS TO
CORRECT MISSING OR MISMATCHED
SIGNATURES ON THEIR VOTE. BY
MAIL BALLOTS AND REQUIRES
CONSISTENT BALLOT REJECTION
REPORTING ACROSS THE STATE- I
FIND MYSELF A LITTLE
CONFLICTED. BECAUSE I YEAH THIS
IS THIS YEAH I CAME FROM A
STUDY FROM STANFORD I NOW
REPRESENT STANFORD AS WELL
CENTER BACKER- BUT SAID THAT-
BUT STANFORD DID REJECT ME
THREE TIMES. SO THEY CLEARLY
HAVE TERRIBLE JUDGMENT SO I'M
NOT SURE. ABOUT THE YOU KNOW
INTELLIGENCE OF THIS THIS
PROPOSALBUT WE'LL GO WITH IT
FOR NOW. HAPPY TO RECOMMEND
SUPPORT WITHIN THEM AS OUTLINED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN- HI. BERMAN I SAY ARE
CHAU ON YOUR BEHALF MARK NO.
THANK YOU SENT A OUR CHILDREN
NOW THEN IT. THEN IT HI LOW.
MAYES MAY AYE MULLIN BLANCA
RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I. FORTY ONE
THAT'S OUT THAT'S OUT FOR ONE
OKAY THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- IT'S CENTER BACK OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
YOUR NEXT BILL IT SB FIVE OH
FOUR. I WILL THANK YOU. SO
CALIFORNIANS HAVE CONTINUED TO
SHOW STRONG DESIRE TO
ENFRANCHISED. JUSTICE INVOLVED
AND FORMERLY INCARCERATED
VOTERS. HOWEVER THIS IS REALLY
BEEN HINDERED BY INCOMPLETE AND
INACCURATE INFORMATION. THAT
LEAVES ELECTION OFFICIALS
MAKING EDUCATED GUESSES AS THE
POINT WAS MADE EARLIER. AS A
TEMP TO KEEP VOTER REGISTRATION
RECORDS UP TO DATE.
ADDITIONALLY MILITARY OVERSEE
VOTERS AS WELL DISABLED VOTERS
ARE CURRENTLY BARRED. FROM
UTILIZING SAME DAY OR
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
OPTIONS. THAT ARE AVAILABLE. TO
VOTERS. IN STATE GIVEN THE
GEOGRAPHIC FOR MOBILITY
LIMITATIONS. SB FIVE BEFORE
WILL ENSURE BETTER MANAGEMENT
BUT JUSTICE INVOLVED
CALIFORNIANS IN A VOTER ROLLS
BY STREAMLINING BASIC
MAINTENANCE PROCESSES FOR
EXAMPLE CDCR WILL BE REQUIRED
TO SEND A WEEKLY FEED DIRECTLY
TO ALL THE COUNTY REGISTRARS.
AND CORRECTED AND HAVE VERY
CLEAR INFORMATION IT ALSO
EXTENDS EXISTING VOTER
REGISTRATION OPTIONS TO ALL
VOTERS WHETHER IN STATE AT HOME
FOR SERVING OVERSEAS. I THINK
THAT YOUR STAFF FOR THE
CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP ANALYSIS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE FOR THIS BILL WE HAVE
OF RYAN ROCCO WAS A PLASTER
COUNTY CLERK. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
ON THE LINE. GREAT THANK YOU
CENTER RECORDS SO WHEN I MOVED
TO PRIMER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
MISTER RONCO I BELIEVE- HE
WASN'T ABLE TO MAKE A QUICK. WE
NOW HAVE VISUAL. WE'LL GET A
LAST MINUTE SUB OKAY- TRICIA
WEBER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS IN
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS I BELIEVE
IS TESTIFYING- VIA TELEPHONE.
THE MORNING CARE BERMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY YES I
AM SURE SHOW EVER. THE SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY CLERK REGISTRAR OF
VOTERS AND THE CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE- I'M
CONTAINING FOR RYAN WHO HAD A
LAST MINUTE CHANGE OF SCHEDULE.
WE ARE PLEASED TO SPONSOR SB
FIVE OH FOUR. I'D LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR BACKGROUND AND STAFF
FOR THEIR IMPORTANT WORK ON THE
BILL. SB FIVE OH FOUR SIX TO
FIX A DESIGN FLAW IN THE
CURRENT LAW WITH RESPECT TO
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION.
RIGHT NOW CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION REQUIRES THE
PERSON WISHING TO REGISTER AND
VOTE FOURTEEN DAYS PRIOR TO AND
THROUGH ELECTION DAY TO BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT EITHER AT.
THE ELECTION OFFICIALS OFFICE
RIGHT APPOINT PLACER VOTE
CENTER IN ORDER TO COMPLETE
THAT REGISTRATION AND THEN
VOTE. HOWEVER THIS LEADS
OVERSEE CITIZENS MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY DEPLOYED BOTH
DOMESTICALLY AND ABROAD AND
HOMEBOUND DISABLED CITIZENS OUT
OF LUCK IF THEY WISH TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF LATE VOTER
REGISTRATION. AND VOTING. TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM SB FIVE OH
FOUR ALLOWS MILITARY AND
OVERSEAS CITIZENS WHO ACCESSED
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
OPPORTUNITIES AND HAVE THEIR
BALLOTS DELIVERED TO THEM
THROUGH THEIR COUNTIES REMOTE
ACCESSIBLE VOTE BY MAIL SYSTEM.
DOES PLACING THEM ON EQUAL
FOOTING WITH THEIR STATESIDE
COUNTERPARTS. IT ALSO ALLOWS
DISABLED CITIZENS WHO CANNOT
PHYSICALLY APPEAR TO REGISTER
AND VOTE DURING THIS PERIOD
ANOTHER OPTION TO PARTICIPATE.
SB FIVE OH FOUR ALSO IMPROVES
VOTER FILE MAINTENANCE BY
HAVING THE DATA FOR THOSE
IMPRISONED FOR A FELONY
CONVICTION HELLO DIRECTLY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION INTO VOEPEL
OUR STATEWIDE VOTER DATABASE.
CURRENTLY REGISTRARS ACROSS THE
STATE RECEIVE DATA ON JUSTICE
INVOLVED PERSONS FROM THEIR
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT ON A
PERIODIC BASIS. HOWEVER THIS
DATA FROM SUPERIOR COURT CAN BE
INCOMPLETE R LACKING IMPORTANT
MATCHING CRITERIA LIKE SOCIAL
SECURITY OR DRIVER'S LICENSE
NUMBER. THESE ARE ITEMS THAT WE
USE TO DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS WITH COMMON NAMES
AND SIMILAR BIRTHDATE. THIS
BILL WILL MANDATE THAT
INFORMATION AUTOMATE THE
PROCESS AND INCREASE THE
FREQUENCY OF DATA SUBMISSION
WHICH WILL IMPROVE VOTER
REGISTRATION FILE MAINTENANCE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY THANK YOU CAN I AM
AVAILABLE TO HELP ENERGY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
WONDERFUL THANK YOU MS WEBER.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANY
PRIMER WHEN THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION WHICH WE HAVE NONE
SO WILL NOW MOVE ON TO-
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE OH
FOUR AS A REMINDER THE PUBLIC
WILL FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL
TIME. FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME OF THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY IN A POSITION
ON THE BILL WILL START IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHICH IS TO PROVIDE
THE POSITION ON SB FIVE OH
FOUR. SEEING NONE. KICK IT OVER
TO THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE WILL NOW OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
THEIR POSITION ON SB FIVE OH
FOR MODERATE OR DO WE HAVE ANY
BODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK EITHER IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB FIVE OH FOUR.
JERRY MANDER GOOD LUCK TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE ZERO FOUR PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
OUR FIRST PAYMENT IS FROM THE
LINE NUMBER THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING DOOR
ROSE LEGAL VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND WE THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
STRENGTHENING AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. CONNECT COMMENT
IS FROM ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SHARE MEMBERS WITH ERIC HARRIS
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO ALSO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US
ON STRENGTHENING THIS BILL AND-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THEM BUT WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL IN A STRONG
WAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME GREAT WILL
BRING BACK THE COLLEAGUES FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO
MOTIONS. QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SEEING NONE SENATOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. J. TO YOUR-
SPORT AND I'VE JUST RESTAURANTS
AND I VOTE THANK YOU SENATE
BACKGROUND LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS BILL FOR
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT MILITARY
AND OVERSEAS VOTERS AND VOTERS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE SAFETY
NET PROVIDED BY ELECTION DAY
REGISTRATION. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL IMPROVES THE ACCURACY AND
RELIABILITY OF CONVICTION DATE
OF THAT ELECTION OFFICIALS
RECEIVED THEREBY IMPROVING THE
ACCURACY OF THE VOTER ROLLS AND
ENSURING THAT ELIGIBLE VOTERS
ARE NOTIFIED WHEN THE VOTING
RIGHTS ARE RESTORED FOR THESE
REASONS I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL VOTE. THE MOST IS
TO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
BERMAN HI BERMAN I SEE ARE
TAILORED SEE OUR TO A BANDIT
BANDIT HI LOW. MAYES MAYES AYE
MULLIN BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA
RUBIO I THAT BILLS OUT WITH
FIVE VOTES WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU SENATOR KERR. NECK I WE
HAVE CENTER ALAN- WITH. TWO
BILLS ON THE AGENDA TODAY AS
BEFORE FOUR FIFTY NINE AND SB
SEVEN FIFTY TWO. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO START WITH SB FOUR FIFTY
NINE CENTER. AS YOU WISH MISTER
CHAIR. AS GOOD A BILL AS ANY
ALL RIGHT- WELL FIRST OFF THANK
YOU HI. MR CHIU I WANNA I WANNA
YOU AND I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LISTENING HOUSES- AND
WE WORK REALLY CLOSELY TOGETHER
I APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK.
I AM AND IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL
SERIES OF AMENDMENTS THAT
BECAUSE WE REALLY DID WANT TO
GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE WERE
DOING NOTHING MORE THAN WAS
ACTUALLY NECESSARY TO REACH OUR
TRANSPARENCY GOALS- I THINK IS.
ELECTED OFFICIALS OUT WE ALL
KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY WE ALL
SPENT ON COMPLIANCE. WITH THE-
HAVE A FILE ARE OUR FILINGS
AND- YOU KNOW I BELIEVE IN THE
RULES THAT STATUS TO THAT PLACE
BUT- EXTRANEOUS FILINGS AND- DO
NOTHING BUT CAUSE. TROUBLE AND
BUREAUCRATIC NIGHTMARES AND
DON'T REALLY PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY FOR
FOLKS. WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE.
IS PROVIDING THE PUBLIC THE
PRESS AND- SOME RESPECTS JUST
AS IMPORTANT MORE IMPORTANT.
FELLOW LAWMAKERS MORE TIMELY
AND USEFUL INFORMATION ABOUT
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SPENT
TO INFLUENCE THE FATE OF
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA. SO
IN OUR STATE LOBBYING FIRMS AND
INTEREST GROUPS HIRING THAT
MUST FILE QUARTERLY REPORTS ON
THEIR LOBBYING ACTIVITY ONE
MONTH AFTER THE CLOSE OF EACH
QUARTER. SO THE THIRD QUARTER
REPORT. OUR COVERAGE THE MOST
SUBSTANTIAL AND MOST
SIGNIFICANT LEGISLATIVE QUARTER
OF THE YEAR AS JULY TO
SEPTEMBER WHICH OF COURSE
INCLUDES THE END OF SESSION.
NOW WE ALL KNOW WHAT WE MOST OF
US KNOW. YOU SEVEN OUT HERE
KNOWS THE CHAOS OF THE END OF
SESSION- MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
LITTLE YOUR SPENT- TO INFLUENCE
LEGISLATION. BUT THE
INTERESTING THING IS THE
DISCLOSURE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CONTRACTS. THE LOBBYING
CONTRACTS THAT DID NOT OCCUR
UNTIL AFTER THE LEGISLATURE IS
ACTUALLY ALREADY DECIDED WHICH
BILLS TO PASS OR DEFEAT AND IN
FACT AFTER THE GOVERNOR. HAS
DECIDED WHICH BILLS TO SIGN OR
VETO. SO THIS ULTIMATELY FAILS
TO PROVIDE ANY USEFUL REAL
TIME. I OR EVEN CLOSE TO TIME
DISCLOSURES ARE TRANSPARENCY
WHEN THAT WHILE THE FATE OF
LEGISLATION IS DECIDED. TO
NEARLY HALF OF THE STATE IN THE
UNION. VIED FOR MONTHLY
REPORTING OR IN SOME INSTANCES
MORE EVEN MORE FREQUENT
REPORTING. I HADN'T IT'S MY
STRONG FEELING THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO DO MORE TO ENSURE THAT
POLICYMAKERS THE PRESS AND THE
PUBLIC HAVE MORE TIMELY AND
USEFUL INFORMATION. ABOUT THE
LOBBYING IMPACTING PUBLIC
POLICY. I THINK WE'VE ALL BEEN
IN SITUATIONS WHERE- FOLKS OR
SOMETHING COMING IN IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO OUR OWN BILLS.
WE HAVE AN AND HAVE NO IDEA WHO
THEY'RE WORKING FOR- AND
EXACTLY WELL YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
THE PLAY AS- SO WHILE THE
COMMITTEE SO NOW. I'M WE DID
HAVE A MONTHLY REPORTING
REQUIREMENT ARE BILL AND WE'RE
TAKING IT OUT. AND YOU KNOW THE
ONE WITHIN THE SPIRIT OF OUR
BROADER GOAL OF TRYING TO DO
NOTHING THAT WE WOULD THAT
WOULD BE THAT THAT THEY WOULD
CAUSE A LOT OF UNNECESSARY
PAPERWORK WITHOUT PROVIDING THE
GOALS THAT. WE HAVE IN TERMS OF
TRANSPARENCY ESPECIALLY AT THE
END OF SESSION BUT HERE'S THE
IMPORTANT THING. THE BILL'S
GOING TO REQUIRE REPORTING FOR
ALL NEWLY HIRED LOBBYISTS
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS IF
THEY'RE HIRED WITHIN THE LAST
SIXTY DAYS OF SESSION. IT WILL
ALSO REQUIRE SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT DETAILING WHAT BILLS
THEY'RE WORKING ON AND WHAT
WHICH CLIENT POSITION A
REPRESENTING. WITHIN THAT THE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS AFTER THEY
BEGIN LOBBYING. UNDER THE BILL
QUARTERLY REPORTS SO WE'RE
WE'RE GETTING RID OF THE
MONTHLY REPORTING RQUIREMENT
BUT WE'RE- SLIGHTLY EXPANDING
THE QUARTERLY REPORT
REQUIREMENTS. SO THOSE
QUARTERLY REPORTS WOULD BE
EXPANDED SO THAT WE COULD SEE
NOT JUST WHAT BILLS WERE
LOBBIED ON BUT THE POSITION
TAKEN. I HAVE YOU KNOW
ULTIMATELY THIS IS ABOUT GIVING
FOLKS THE OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW
WHO'S LOBBYING FOR AND AGAINST
LEGISLATION HOW LOBBYING
INFLUENCES LAWS BEING MADE. ON
THE OTHER IMPORTANT THING TO
MENTION IS THAT WE'RE SEEING A
PLETHORA OF. OF ADVOCACY BASED
ADVERTISEMENTS. THAT ARE JUST
BEING DIRECTED TO US AND TO OUR
STAFF THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA. I'D
LIKE A FULL PAGE AD IN THE
SACRAMENTO BEE WHICH IS OPEN TO
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC TO SEE.
ARE THESE ADS ARE ARE BEING
MICRO TARGETED AND THEY ARE.
BEING BOUGHT TO PROVIDE THE
SENSE THAT THERE'S KIND OF A
MASSIVE LOBBYING CAMPAIGN
ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN OR
GRASSROOTS CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATED
WITH THE- SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
TO A PARTICULAR BILL USUALLY.
I'M OF COURSE THE TRUTH IS IT'S
ACTUALLY BEING MICROTARGETING
TO US IN IS NOT AVAILABLE TO
THE GENERAL PUBLIC AND- INTO
THE INTO THE PRESS. SO I'M SO
WE ALSO WANT TO PUT SOME OF THE
DISCLOSURE RULES THAT RELATE TO
CAMPAIGN ADVERTISING ON TO
THESE ISSUE ADVOCACY CAMPAIGNS.
I SAID IT NOW YOU KNOW PEOPLE
HAVE TO REPORT SPENDING ON ADS
WITHIN SEVENTY TWO HOURS INTO
THE BILL. AND ALSO REQUIRES IT
INTEREST GROUPS TO PUT THEIR
NAMES ON THE ADS- THERE'S A-
SOME OF YOURS I WAS LOOKING
ROUGH AND TUMBLE THE OTHER DAY
AND- IT'S AMAZING HOW MANY
DIFFERENT. MODES THE
ADVERTISERS ARE TAKING SOME ARE
BEING VERY. UP FRONT ABOUT
WHO'S PAYING FOR THEIR ADS
OTHERS ARE LEGALLY PRESENTING
NO INFORMATION WHATSOEVER AS TO
WHO'S- WHO'S PAYING FOR THE ADS
SO. HOW WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS WE WANT TO WORK WITH
OUR PARTNERS I WHO REPRESENT
THE- THE THIRD HOUSE THE
pWITH THEM SEVERAL TIMES AND ARE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THEM TO GET TO A
PLACE. WHERE WE FEEL GOOD ABOUT
THIS BILL- THE BILL RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN VERY STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
SENATE I AND THEY WILL PROVIDE
COMMONSENSE SOLUTIONS FOR
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY IN OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THE PUBLIC
THE PRESS LIKE IT OFFICIALS
DESERVE. WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS JONATHAN
STEIN WHOSE EXECUTIVE COMMON
CAUSE INDOOR ROSE ANOTHER
EXECUTIVE THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS. THANK YOU- CENTER ALLEN
ENDS I BELIEVE- BOTH. JONATHAN
MATTISE DIçN INDOOR ROSE ARE
TESTIFYING BY TELEPHONE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD-
IDENTIFYING OPEN THEIR LINES
AND REMINDER- WHEN THIS ISN'T
SUPPORT HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH.
INFO SIGNS ARE OPEN. SURE
BERMAN AND MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JONATHAN ABOUT THE
STEIN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA COMMON COST OUT WE
ARE SPONSORED BEFORE NINE
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO UP
FRONT OFFER MY SINCERE
GRATITUDE OF COURSE CENTER
ALLEN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP BUT
ALSO TO YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
COSIDERATION OF THIS BILL AND
HERE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT WORK. SB FOUR FIFTY
NINE DOES SUPPORT THE FIRST TO
CREATE A REAL TIME TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT BOBBING IN THE CAPITAL AT
THE END OF SESSION BOB
REPORTING BECOME POORLY UNDER
OUR MENTION MEANING THAT THE
DISCLOSURES THAT OFFER YOU YOUR
STAFF AND THE PUBLIC THE CHANCE
TO KNOW WHO IS LOBBYING WHAT AT
THE END OF SESSION COME AFTER
ANY OF THAT INFORMATION IS
ACTUALLY USEFUL. IF AN INTEREST
GROUP HIRED LOBBYISTS RIGHT
YEAH THE SECTION WE DON'T FIND
OUT UNTIL AFTER THE LEGISLATURE
ADJOURNS AND THE BILL TARGETED
HAVE BEEN KILLED OR PASSED OUT
WHAT BUT THEY WERE LOBBYING ON
PEOPLE HAVE NOT CHANGED THAT
THE LAWMAKERS AND THE PUBLIC
RIGHT AWAY. WHO HAS BEEN HIRED
TO LOBBY AGAINST BILLS. BACK SB
FORTY NINE WOULD REQUIRE FILER
AND BOBBY. WHO HAVE ALL. WITH
WHICH BILL THEY LOBBIED ON. TO
ALSO. THAT TAKEN ON THE OF
THOSE THAT. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
CAR SENSE SHOW THOUGH IT MAY
LOBBYIST ORDERS MORE. THIRD SB
FORTY NINE INCREASE THE- PANTS.
AND ON ISSUES. ECONOMICALLY AND
ON IT PRESSURE WHILE. FOR THE
FIRST TIME THOSE AT HAPTIC THE
NAME OF THE INTEREST GROUP PAID
FOR THE- FOURTH AND FINALLY THE
BILL BECAUSE SMALL CHANGES
THANK A LOT OF REPORTING MORE
MODERNIZED AND IF YOU'RE GONNA
LOBBYIST THEMSELVES. WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT AND A
CHANCE TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
OF VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
BILL. AMONG THE MEMBERS TO GET
THE BACK MANY STAFF WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE HAVE AGREED
TO AMEND THE BILL. THAT WOULD
NOT GO INTO EFFECT UNTIL ONE
FULL YEAR AFTER THE NEW CAL ACT
THAT LOBBYIST OF THE SYSTEM
GOES LIVE. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE IS
PROUD TO HAVE THE SUPPORT OF
THE GOOD GOVERNMENT COMMUNITY
PLEASE COMMONSENSE REFORMS.
THAT WILL BRING GREATER
SUNSHINE FOR POLITICAL SYSTEM
AND TO OUR CAPITAL. THANK YOU
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE
VOTE ON. REPORT BEING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MS ROSE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MORNING
MEMBERS OF THIS IS YOUR ROSE
I'M TO DIVISION DIRECTOR WITH
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. THANKS FOR HAVING
ME HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF THE SPEED FOR FIVE NINE
TODAY. REALLY ALSO A VERY.
LEGAL RIGHT TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIANS KNOW WHO'S
SPENDING LARGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY
TO INFLUENCE LEGISLATION THAT'S
BEING MADE IN THEIR NAME. I
THINK WE'VE GOT REALLY
MEANINGFUL WAYS TO CHECK. THE
PUBLIC PROMISES ESPECIALLY THE
PROMISES OF LARGE CORPORATIONS
MATCH THEIR LOBBYING
ACTIVITIES. THE PUBLIC THE
PRESS LEGISLATORS THAT WE ALL
DESERVE IT INSIDE IS A SPECIAL
INTERESTS THAT MY PEOPLE HAVING
BEHIND THE SCENES TO PROMOTED
TO KILL BILL. AND THE TIMING ON
THIS DISCLOSURE IS REALLY
CRITICAL RIGHT IT DOESN'T HELP
TO FIND OUT WHO SPENDING
MILLIONS TO INFLUENCE
LEGISLATION AFTER IT'S ALREADY
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR. THAT'S
INFORMATION WE ALL NEED TO HAVE
ALL THE STOPPAGES BEING MADE.
SB FOUR FIFTY NINE WE'RE WILL
IMPROVE LOBBYING TRANSPARENCY
BY REQUIRING SPECIFIC POSITIONS
THAT ARE BEING TAKEN ON THE L.
G. NOTED IN QUARTERLY REPORTS
SO WE KNOW PEOPLE WHERE PEOPLE
STAND- IT'S ALSO GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET. TIMELY
DISCLOSURES OF NEW LOBBYISTS
AND THEIR WORK DURING THAT.
PERIOD AT THE END OF SESSION.
OPEN THIS IS REALLY GOING TO BE
BENEFICIAL TO THE PROCESS
OVERALL. YOU KNOW IF IT'S CLEAR
WHERE EVERYONE STANDS ON A BILL
THERE'S JUST A MORE NATURAL
EXCHANGE IDEAS THAT UNFOLDS AND
THAT GIVEN TAKE REALLY
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO IMPROVED
LEGISLATIVE OUTCOMES SO THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT SB FOUR
FIFTY NINE. WE THANK SENATOR
ALAN FOR HIS EADERSHIP ON
MATTERS OF TRANSPARENCY AND
GOOD GOVERNMENT IN GENERAL WE
URGE I. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WILL NOW MOVE TO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM TODAY.
JUSTIN BROWN AND DOMINIC-
DOMINIC TOMARI- YOU'RE WELCOME
TO PRESENT FROM THE MICROPHONE
COME UP TO THE TO THE TABLE
WHATEVER WE HAVE ONE CHAIR HERE
BUT WE CAN GET ANOTHER ONE
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT. SOME FOLDING
CHAIRS IN THE BACK. SO WHATEVER.
MAKES YOU. CHARLOTTE OF. AND
REMIND YOU GOT TWO MINUTES FOR
EACH. PRIMARY ONE IS ANOTHER.
CHAIRMAN OF M. MY NAME IS
DOMINIC TO. AND I HERE IN MY
COULD. AS THE VOTE. PRO HE YOUR
THAT AREN'T YOU YEAH THE TO THE
LIST ASIAN THAT RIVER LOBBY
HERE IN FACT- AND IT'S BEEN MY
GREAT. TO LEAD THIS COMMUTE
THIS COMMUNITY EFFORT- IN THIS
TIME OF. THE PANDEMIC AND THIS
BILL- WE APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
THAT THE COMMITTEES DONE WE
APPRECIATE SOME OF THE MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN MADE THE WORK THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH THE SNATOR AND
HIS STAFF WE DO REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT A FEW ITEMS-
AGAIN YOU KNOW AS POINTED OUT
IN. THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- THE
F. T. P. C. WENT ORIGINALLY
PASSING THE LAWS THAT WERE
AMENDING TODAY DID SO IN ORDER
TO SIMPLIFY AND MAKE MORE SORT
OF UNIFORMS THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT BEFALL
LOBBYIST HERE AND SO THIS FEELS
LIKE WE'RE MOVING IN A LITTLE
BIT OF THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
AND THAT WERE COMPLICATING IT
TO A CERTAIN EXTENT- AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE RELATIVE AND-
PROPOSED AND WILL BE ADOPTED.
THE TWO AREAS THAT I WILL
HIGHLIGHT TONIGHT TO THIS
MORNING WILL BE ONE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT I DON'T
KNOW THAT I. G. HAS A PROBLEM
WITH THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
REPORTING AS A CONCEPT IN IN IN
IN PRACTICE. HOWEVER THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT DOES IT
CREATE AN ADDITIONAL BURDEN
PARTICULARLY ON THE SMALL SOLE
PROPRIETOR SHOPS WHERE AT THE
END THE SESSION PARTICULARLY
THE SIXTY DAYS WE FIND
OURSELVES CONSTANTLY BEING
APPROACHED BY OUR COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE WORKING ON ISSUES. TO
JOIN IN EFFORTS ON BILLS THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN RECENTLY AMENDED
COMING OUT OF EITHER THE LAST
POLICY COMMITTEE OR OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS AND OFTEN TIMES
GOING INTO THE PREPARATIONS FOR
INSTANCE THE BILL WON'T HAVE
THE MOMENTS THAT WILL MAKE ANY
INDIVIDUAL LOBBYIST FOR OTHER
CLIENTS OPPOSED HOWEVER COMING
OUT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT IT DOES
AND THEN THERE'S A SHORT
TURNAROUND TIME. UNTIL THE BILL
HITS THE FLOOR AND THIRTY MORE
SECONDS HAVING THAT REQUIREMENT
IS GOING TO BE A BURDEN ON THE
SOLE PROPRIETORS OF
PARTICULARLY IF IT'S A OF LARGE
DRAFT THE BILLS. THE SECOND
ISSUE I WOULD BRING UP IS A
FIRST AMENDMENT ISSUE SORT OF
WRAP. AROUND THE ISSUE ADVOCACY.
WE HAPPENS IF I PUT MY AD MY TO
OR MY- I. G. POST. OUT ON A
FRIDAY I CAN'T MAKE THE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR. REQUIREMENT RIGHT
IT'S ALMOST AS IF THAT'S
ALMOST- INDIRECT PRIOR
RESTRAINT BECAUSE IT SAYS TO
ME- I CAN'T DO THIS OR
SHOULDN'T DO THIS BECAUSE I
CAN'T REPORT WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS. ALSO I'M ALSO A LITTLE
BIT BOTHERED BY THE LACK OF
RECIPROCITY. WERE RECIPROCAL.
OBLIGATION ON THE LEGISLATOR
THE LAW MAKER OR THE OFFICIAL
THEMSELVES. BECAUSE THEY CAN
TWEET OR OR IG POST. AND NOT
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO TELL ME
IF I'M THE SUBJECT OF THAT POST
THANK MIZEN ARE SO THOSE ARE
CONCERNS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO MISTER
BROWN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERS CHRIS BROWN
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS UNION OF- EDUCATORS IN
CLASS BY PROFESSIONALS- WE'RE
IMMENSELY GRATEFUL FOR THE
CONTINUING WORK THAT'S GOING ON
BETWEEN THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND
ALL OF OUR CONCERNS- WE REALLY
WANT TO RECOGNIZED THE GREAT
STRIDES FORWARD IN THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE. THAT HAVE
OCCURRED WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO CONTINUING WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON THIS BILL
AND SPONSORS AS WELL- WE'RE
DOWNGRADING OUR OPPOSITION TO
YOU KNOW A HEIGHTENED LEVEL OF
CONCERN- WHICH I THINK GOES TO
SOME OF THE- THE INTERESTING
QUESTIONS OF THE PRAXIS OF THIS
BILL WENT TO BECOMES INACTIVE
IS THAT. RIGHT NOW HERE I AM
SAYING WHO I AM WHAT I'M DOING
IT LIVE IN REAL TIME WHICH THAT
CAN BE VIEWED BY ANYONE IN
CALIFORNIA OR THE ENTIRE WORLD
ON THE INTERNET. AND EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO IN WRITING IS PUBLIC
RECORD AS WELL SO THERE'S LIKE
A BIT OF A QUESTION ABOUT HOW
MUCH THAT IS GOING ON REAL TIME
IS HIDDEN- WE CAN'T SPEAK ON
ANYTHING WITHOUT LETTING YOU
KNOW OUR NAME RANK SERIAL
NUMBER MEETING. OUR
ORGANIZATION AND OUR POSITIONS
BUT EVEN THE POSITIONS GET A
LITTLE BIT GRAY AREA SOMETIMES
THERE'S ALSO QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW YOU KNOW WHAT IS DIRECT
COMMUNICATION WITH OFFICES.
OFTENTIMES WE KNOW I MIGHT BE
STANDING IN LINE UP IN THE
SIXTH FLOOR FOR COFFEE AND I
SEE A STAFF AND I SAY. OH HEY
TERRA HOW ARE WE ON S. B. BALL
THE BLINDS- JUST GIVE ME A
THUMBS UP. DOES THAT TRIGGER
TWENTY FOUR HOUR REPORT NOW
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN THESE ARE
THE KINDS OF QUESTIONS THAT I
THINK WE STILL HAVE AND TO WORK
OUT AND SIT DOWN AND- OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE IT IS MADE IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO HAVE. REAL
CONVERSATIONS ON THESE MATTERS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING HOUGH ON THIS SO-
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE YELLOW FLAG
STILL TO GO AND ECHO THE
COMMENTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE
BY THE IDA. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS-
JUST TO STAND DOWN A COUPLE
MORE ROUGH EDGES THERE SO
CREATE THE TIME. THANK YOU
MISTER BROWN IT WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AS A
REMINDER THE PUBLIC OFF FIFTEEN
MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO WRITING THEIR NAME.
THE ORGANIZATION. THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY IN A POSITION
ON THE- WILL START IN THE CAN.
ROOM THERE ANYWAY IN THE ROOM
WHO WITH HIS. EITHER POSITION.
ON SB FOUR FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN- MEMBERS
TERRY BRENNAN BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA. ECHO THE SENTIMENTS
BY WORKING WITH- YOUR TEAM.
SENATE ALLEN STEAM. WE STILL
REMAIN OPPOSED BUT HOPEFUL OR
IN DIRECT NEGOTIATIONS RIGHT
NOW AS WE SPEAK THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE MORNING
CATHERINE BRANDENBURG WITH THE
BRAND EVENT GROUP I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT NINETY EIGHT AND
WE'RE ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING CENTER BOROUGH ON
BEHALF OF CSEA- WE WERE OPPOSED
BUT- WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- SPECIFICALLY
REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT. TO
FILE MONTHLY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MOVING TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES- IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE- LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES- THE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WHO WOULD
RATHER POSITION ON S. B. FOUR
FIFTY NINE A MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK EITHER IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE
FIFTY NINE. TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR S. B. FOUR FIVE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ENTER
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. FIRST
COM- COMPLAINT NUMBER TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I DO
APOLOGIZE WILL GO TO LINE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS CHRISTY BAMA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
ASSOCIATE MY REMARKS WITH
JACKSON BROWNE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OVERLAND SIXTEEN
YOU'RE LYING IN THE OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO STEPHANIE BROWN
ON BEHALF OF TOGETHER WE WILL
INDIVISIBLE OF LESS CONTENT. WE
URGE YOU TO PASS OFF BE FOUR
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BORDERLANDS THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS BIGGER MONITOR
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE CURRENTLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE BUT THE MANAGEMENT
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE- WE'RE
CURRENTLY REVIEWING THEM AND WE
HOPE TO- FIND OURSELVES IN THE
SAME POSITION HAS REFERENCED BY
MR BROWN EARLIER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. TOTALING
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING CHAIR NUMBERS ON THE
SHELF OTHER DIRECTOR OF MùT
MONEY OUT VOTERS AND- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FIFTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS SO CONFUSING YOU'RE NOT
FOLLOWING THE AGENDA AND I'M
TRYING TO OPPOSED THE NEWMAN
BILL WE WILL GET NEWMAN BILL
ARE I APOLOGIZE MA'AM NEWMAN
NEWMAN BILL HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM THE AGENDA SO THE NEWMAN
BILL WILL NOT BE HEARD THAT
TODAY OR OR THIS YOU KNOW THAT
WHEN YOU'RE NOT EVEN FOLLOWING
THE AGENDA HE MADE THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE HEARING I APPRECIATE
YOUR WAY- OPERATOR. MOVE ON
INTO THE NIGHT LAWLER THANK YOU.
BERLING SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH JENNIFER TURNER HERE
ON BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA GREEN TEAM AND
VOEPEL THREE FIFTY WE AREN'T
STRONG SUPPORT SB FOUR FIFTY
NINE AM THANK COUNTERBALANCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY
NANCY NOW VOLUNTEER WITH
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
AND IN STRONG SUPPORTER SB FOUR
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DAVID NEWS
WENGER FROM SUNNYVALE- A MEMBER
OF CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY AND-
I SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I ENDED
BURKE ONLY CUT ME OFF LAST TIME
BECAUSE I WOULD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK TO THE BILL THAT'S
CURRENTLY ON THE AGENDA WHICH
IS AS BEFORE FIFTY NINE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR NAME ANY
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITHIN YOUR
POSITION ON SB FOUR FIFTY NINE
THAT IS THE PART OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARING THAT WE'RE AT
CURRENTLY. THE GLOUCESTER. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
STERN UNITE. THAT OPEN TO HAVE
SOMEBODY ON THE LINE STILL
LYING. YES ARE AT I'M ON
PRIMARY WITNESS LIKE PRINT
LAYING A CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY-CAMPAIGN THAT'S BUT YEAH YOU'RE
OUT YOU'RE UP NEXT MY FRIEND
YOU'RE UP NEXT SO THAT'S GONNA
BE SB SEVEN NO LIGHT BY
DEFAULT. I THOUGHT I WANT TO
SAY THAT THAT HELP WOMEN
CAMPAIGN IS ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FIFTY NINE
PERFECT THANK YOU MAKE IT. THE
THANK YOU TRENT APPRECIATE THAT-
AND WE'LL TALK YOU REAL SOON.
MR MAYES. YEAH ADJUSTED A
COUPLE THINGS I DON'T KNOW- IF
IT'D BE OK MISTER CHAIR TO
HAVE- THE GENTLEMAN. MISTER
MISTER TOMARI FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
ASSOCIATIONS- COME BACK. TO IF
YOU WANT TO IF. I'LL LET YOU
DECIDE MR TOMAR. NO GOOD DEED
GOES UNPUNISHED. VIEW THE EVEN
KNOW THE HALF BEEN NO I DON'T
AND I DON'T WANT YOU. YES SIR
NOT SO BUT IF YOU WERE ACTUALLY
MAKING SOME OF US SOME GOOD
POINT THAT BUT I'M INCLINED
JUST TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF- OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE ESPECIALLY-
IN REGARD TO THE TRANSPARENCY
IN THOSE FINAL. COUPLE OF
MONTHS- BUT IF YOU CAN TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SORT OF THAT
TWENTY FOUR HOUR APPEAR TO NOTE
FOR POLITICAL CAMPAIGN FOR ALL
USED TO THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
REPORTING PERIOD. I THINK IN
REGARDS THE POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS
IT MAKES AND THAT MAKES AN
AWFUL LOT OF SENSE I'M NOT SURE
THAT. THAT THAT TWENTY FOUR
HOURS- IS THE BEST ONE ON YES
THE ADDRESS THAT FRIDAY
AFTERNOON- IS THERE SOME WAY
THAT YOU CAN GET THE THAT YOU
GUYS CAN GET THEIR BE BEYOND
THE TWENTY FOUR HOURS MAYBE MAY
HAVE THAT THE AUTHOR. TO TALK
ABOUT IT I MEAN IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THE BILL IT'S THE
WORK THAT WE'VE WE'RE IT WE
WENT IT SEVENTY TWO HOURS FOR
THEM REPORTER. ISSUE AT
SPENDING AS OPPOSED TO TWENTY
FOUR. WELL IF THAT'S NOT THE
CASE THAT GET THAT FOR. BLOOD
THE A THERE'S REQUIRE IN THEIR
I READ CORRECTLY THAT IT'S
TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO USE THE
INDIVIDUAL. LEGISLATOR THAT IS.
MENTIONED OR THE ISSUE THAT
YOU'RE CARRYING IS MENTIONED IT
SEVENTY TWO HOURS TO THE
APPROPRIATE RECEIVING. ENTITY
RIGHT AHA SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
ISSUES LIKE IT'S TWENTY FOUR
HOURS TO. YOU KNOW IF I DO AN
ISSUE THAT. HAS DEFINED IN THE
BILL- OR MY CLIENT DOES ONE WE
HAVE TO COME AND TALK YOU KNOW
SEND YOU COMMUNICATIONS- THAT
SAYS WE'RE DOING THE ALBUM THIS
IS WHAT IT'S ABOUT THIS IS
WHERE AN AND WE ALSO HAVE TO.
SAY A WORD WAS POSTED IN ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT ADDITIONAL-
BITS OF INFORMATION. SO I JUST
WANT THEM THINKING THERE IF
THAT CAN BECAUSE I COULDN'T
AGAIN UNDERSTAND FOR
TRANSPARENCY SAKE WE WANT WHEN
WE HAVE INFORMATION I AGREE
WITH- THE AUTHOR ON THIS THAT
ESPECIALLY. TOWARDS THE END
DOES THE WHEN THINGS ARE GOING
CRAZY- THAT LAST- A COUPLE OF
WEEKS. IN IN PARTICULAR- BUT
PEOPLE ARE SHOWING UP IN YOUR
OFFICE ARETALKING ABOUT THESE
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHO THEY ARE
WHO THEY REPRESENT A WHAT. A
WHAT'S GOING I DO THINK THAT
THAT SUPPORT I JUST WONDER IF
THAT TWENTY FOUR HOURS IS TOO
SHORT MAYBE THAT SHOULD EXTEND
A LITTLE BIT LONGER MAYBE WE
CAN WE CAN GET THERE. CAN I
JUST ADD ONE MORE JUST
ADDITIONAL THING FOR THE- ORDER
AND THIRD CHAIR IF I MAY
PLEASE- THERE YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE INFORMATION AND IN
PARTICULAR THE MATTER OF THE
ACTION RIGHT. I CAN SEE AN
ISSUE IN THE BILL IN DURING THE
LEGISLATIVE YEAR BUT AT THE END
THE SESSION WHEN WERE IN THAT
SORT OF INTRUM PERIOD WERE WERE
IN OCTOBER NOVEMBER. AND
THERE'S AN ISSUE THAT IS COMING
UP AND WE KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE
AN ISSUE FOR NEXT YEAR. THIS
ALMOST SEEMS LIKE- AND THE
MEANS TO IDENTIFY EARLY. IN
ISSUE THAT MAY BE COMING IN
JANUARY. TO THE- POSSIBLE
DETRIMENT OF THE PEOPLE THAT
MIGHT BE ADVOCATING FOR THAT
ISSUE BECAUSE- OFTENTIMES WE
MEAN THAT. ACTUALLY INTRODUCED
THE BILL BECAUSE OF ALL THE
WORK WE DO IN THE FALL
DETERMINES THAT IS EITHER CAN'T
PASS. WHAT'S NOT THE ISSUE THAT
WE THOUGHT IT WAS. BUT WE DON'T
EVEN GET THE CHART THAT CHANCE
TO BE DELIBERATIVE. BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO REPORT THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE SOME. KIND OF
ACTIVITY ON THAT. MATTER OF
THAT. OR THE ISSUE. AND SO MY
CONCERN WOULD BE REALLY REPORT
HE- JUST IN THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR FOR JUST THE FACT THAT I
HAVE TO REPORT. SOME ISSUE. ADD
AROUND AN ISSUE THAT HASN'T
EVEN BECOME A BILL YET. IS A
CONCERN TO THE LARGER COMMUNITY
THAT I REPRESENT. IN THIS
CAPACITY. AS A VOLUNTEER
PRESIDENT. SO YOU'RE SAYING
YOU'RE TAKING OUT AN AD. AT THE
END OF SESSION OR SOMETHING YOU
MIGHT WANT TO WORK ON IN THE
FUTURE YEAH WE'RE SETTING THE
YOU KNOW YOU'RE SETTING THE
PREDICATE RESETTING THE
PRESIDENT OR- YOU KNOW EVEN
WITH THE REPORTING REQUIREMENT
RIGHT. LIKE I' REPORTING ON
POTENTIALLY ON SOMETHING THAT I
MEAN THAT MAY NEVER BECOME THE
BILL AS A LOBBYIST SO. PROBABLY
LESSER OF A CONCERN BUT IF I'M
TRYING. OR MY- CLIENTS ARE
TRYING OR ANYONE'S TRYING. TO
YOU KNOW AFFECT. IN YOU KNOW
LEGISLATION FOR THE FOLLOWING
YEAR IN THE FALL BY DOING SOME
ADS TO GO AND YOU KNOW GET
PEOPLE SORT OF SENSITIZED TO
THE ISSUE THAT BECOMES
REPORTABLE WHICH I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S NECESSARILY A BAD THING
BUT THE MODALITY IS THAT IT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH SOME SORT OF
LEGISLATIVE ACTION THAT HASN'T
ACTUALLY. HEARD YET THAT MAKES
SENSE YEAH I MEAN IN TERMS
pCHAIR AT YOU KNOW A MONTH SO WE
TURN TO THE REGULATION OF THESE
ADS AT THE END OF SESSION MY
PRIMARY INTEREST IS FOCUSED ON.
THE INFLUENCE RELATING TO THE
VOTES THAT ARE GONNA HAPPEN IN
THE LEGISLATURE SO IF IT'S A
MATTER OF CLARIFYING THAT THIS
HAS TO BE THAT THAT IT WILL BE
THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT THE
THAT THE QUICK REPORT. AT THE
END OF SESSION RULES WOULD
WOULD KICK IN FOR ADVOCACY
DIRECTLY RELATING TO. TO
ACTIONS THAT CAN BE TAKEN BY
THE LEGISLATURE BY THE END OF
SESSION I'M HAPPY TO GET THAT
CLEARED UP IF I PUSH IT AT THE
TIME BECAUSE IN THE END OF THE
DAY YOU'RE RIGHT I MEAN IT THE
TRANSPARENCY CONCERNS THE THIRD
QUICK TRANSPARENCY. CONCERNS
ASSOCIATED WITH. ADVERTISING A
BRA ISSUE IS NOT AS A CUTE
LITTLE AS WHEN YOU'RE PUTTING
IN LAST MINUTE PLAYS. FOR AS
YOU ADDS. UP REALLY TO BILLS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE COMING UP
FOR A VOTE WITHIN A COUPLE DAYS
YEAH. AND I WOULD EVEN GO A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER WELL.
SEPARATE BUT RELATED IS. IF
WE'RE REPORTING IN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS TO A FEW PC OR SECTORS
THAT WHOEVER REPORTING TO- IS
IT STILL NECESSARY TO REPORT TO
THE INDIVIDUAL LEGISLATOR AND
WITHIN A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
PERIOD OF TIME. BREATHLESS I'D
LIKE TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
YEAH AND- THANK YOU PRISM IS A
MESS. MISTER BENNETT OF. FOR
THOSE OF US THAT OF. FOR THOSE
OF US THAT- ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE UNDUE INFLUENCE OF MONEY IN
POLITICS WE'VE BEEN LEFT- BY
THE SUPREME COURT ESSENTIALLY
WITH TRANSPARENCY AS THOSE
REALLY THE ONLY TOOL- THAT WE
HAVE OUT THERE SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS
TO TRY TO INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY AT A CRITICAL TIME
AND I HAVEN'T LIVED THROUGH
THAT YET BUT THAT SAID AND
ASCENSION- INTENSITY- SO I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS. BUT I
DO KNOW THAT- THE OFTENTIMES
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF-
SOME ACTION DON'T GET POINTED
OUT- BY INTEREST GROUPS UNTIL
THEY'VE HAD TIME TO SEE THE
LEGISLATION AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE. SO I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT THE
AUTHOR. HAS COME TODAY AND SAID
I'M TRYING. I'M TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH IS COMMONSENSE THING
AND I DON'T WANT TO HAVE
ANYMORE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THEN- I WANT TO TRY TO ADDRESS
ALL OF THESE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO SO. THIS DIALOGUE HAS
BEEN HELPFUL TO GIVE ME MORE
CONFIDENCE THAT- AS EASY AS
PEOPLE RAISE ISSUES OF THAT
THERE'S A GOOD FAITH EFFORT
BEING MADE TO TRY TO NARROW
THIS DOWN TO THE SPECIFIC GOALS
THAT- THE AUTHORS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH. AND AT THE SAME
TIME TRY TO AVOID THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
ARE OUT THERE SO- WITH THAT. I
HI I GREW CENTER RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS A GOOD FAITH EFFORT
BEING MADE AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT CONTINUING- I
THINK THAT FOR EXAMPLE. GETTING
IT CLARIFIED TODAY THAT. THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATION IS
WHO'S LOBBYING ON A BILL BUT AT
THE END OF SESSION RIGHT IN
FRONT OF THE LEGISLATURE. AND
TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT IT
SHOULDN'T BE INTENDED FOR-
ADVOCACY AT THE END OF OCTOBER
WHEN WE'RE NOT IN SESSION AND
THE BILL HASN'T EVEN BEEN
CREATED SO PERHAPS. CLARIFYING
THAT IS ONLY FOR BILLS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY IT IN A- THERE'S QUITE
A BIT OF ADVOCACY ON
INITIATIVES ETCETERA THAT UNTIL
THE INITIATIVE IS ACTUALLY
FILED THE- YOU DON'T HAVE THE
SAME REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AS
AFTER IT'S FILED THE SAME THING
COULD BE HAPPENING WITH THAT
SO. ANYWAY I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS AND THE GOOD FAITH AND
INTELLIGENT CONVERSATION OR
HAVEN'T BECAUSE COMMONSENSE
LEGISLATION IS BUT CLOSER TO
GOOD GOVERNMENT- THAN THAT THAN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SO
THANK YOU. SEEMS BENT MISTER.
CHAIRMAN OF OYSTERS SORRY
VESTER C. R. DO AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA MISTER MULLIN I THANK
YOU. SIR ON THE SUBJECT OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES ONE OF
MY CONCERNS IS WE WERE WE DO A
LOT OF THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ADD MORE AND MORE
AND. AND HAVE THEM IN TIGHT
WINDOWS. BY WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THEY GET TO. THE DESTINATION OF
THE SECRETARY OF STATE DO THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY OF YOU WORK
WITH THEM TO FIND OUT IF THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO HANDLE
THIS ADDITIONAL LOAD BECAUSE
THERE IS NOTHING MORE
FRUSTRATING. THAN AND I THINK
YOU CAN ASK THE GOVERNOR RIGHT
NOW YEAH AND THEN TRYING TO GET
ALL YOUR PAPERS IN ON TIME AND
THEN YOU GET HIM ON ON TIME AND
THEN YOU FIND OUT THAT THEY
DIDN'T EVEN GET FILED. AND SIX
MONTHS LATER YOU'RE BEING FINED
FOR SOMETHING AND IT JUST IT
JUST WE GOT TO HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO. ENACT
THESE THINGS. THE THROUGH THE
CHAIR THE CAR YOU'RE YOUR
QUESTION IS SPOT ON IT WAS
RAISED IN OUR EARLIER
CONVERSATIONS WITH. WITH THEM
WITH AGA- SO WE DECIDED TO
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION THE BILL
UNTIL ONE OUT ONE YEAR AFTER
CAL ACCESS. IS UP IN THIS PART
THIS THIS PORTION OF CHARACTERS
UP AS UP AND RUNNING. SO I
WHICH YOU KNOW TURNED OUT SO IF
THIS BILL PASSES THE ONUS WILL
BE ON. THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE TO YOU KNOW. GET GO AND
GET THE SYSTEM THAT THEY'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR A LONG
TIME UP AND RUNNING AND THEN IT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED A YEAR
AFTERWARDS. I THINK OKAY THE
MIZ RUSHER WAS MOMENT. THANK
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THE ISSUE
AS YOU KNOW I'VE TAKEN A STAB
AT IT ISSUE AD DISCLOSURE YEAH
AND- ALSO THIS LOBBYING
DISCLOSURE FREQUENCY OF
REPORTING. AND IT'S GOING TO
THAT PROCESS AND I AM PROUD TO
BE THAT THE ASSEMBLY CO AUTHOR
ON THIS AND APPLY YOU FOR IT
IT'S SUPER COMPLICATED IN TERMS
OF HOW THE BILLING WORKS AND
HOW THE REAL SORT OF LOVING
WORLD WORKS AND THEN YOU'VE GOT
THE CAL ACCESS TECHNOLOGY
ISSUE. THIS MULTI LAYERED HERE
AND I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
SINKING UP- THE REBOOT OF
CALLOUT ACCESS- WITH YOUR
EFFORTS I THINK OF THE
FUNCTIONALITY AS PROMISED- IS
GOING TO BE A GREAT IMPROVEMENT
IN TERMS OF HOW THIS ACTUALLY
WORKS FOR THE PUBLIC BUT- IT'S
VERY NEW WANTS AND HOW THESE
THINGS WORK AND I APPRECIATE
THAT MISSION TO MARS COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE YOU ENGAGING THIS
JUST WE WANT TO HAVE A- SYSTEM
THAT. BOB YOU KNOW BLENDS WITH
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN
THE LOBBYING WORLD IN REALLY MY
MOTIVATION WAS IN INITIATING.
WHAT YOU REALLY WANT TO SEE
WHERE THE BIG MONEY IS MOVING
LATE IN THE GAME AND THE LAG
WAS ALWAYS FRUSTRATING TO ME
AND I BY HER. FRANKLY FROM
JOURNALISTS WHO SAID. YOU KNOW
WE WANT TO TRY TO COVER THIS
STUFF BUT BY THE TIME WE SEE
THE DISCLOSURE. YOU KNOW THE
BILLS ALREADY YOU KNOW- THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE TO THE
GOVERNOR. AND THE PUBLIC.
DOESN'T HAVE THE ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE THE BIG
DOLLARS ARE MOVING AND THAT WAS
AND I APPRECIATE THE THRESHOLD.
I YOU PUT IN HERE AS WELL SO- I
APPRECIATE THE REFINEMENTS
YOU'VE MADE AYE AYE. I'M
GRATEFUL YOU'RE YOU'RE TAKING
IT UP- BLOOD IT ALSO- POINTS TO
JUST. NEEDING TO CRAFT
SOMETHING. THAT HAS SORT OF-
CONTINGENCIES IN PLACE SO WHEN
THE CAL ACCESS SYSTEM. IS
REBOOTED THAT FUTURE
REFINEMENTS COULD BE MADE SO WE
HAVE SOMETHING THAT- INCREASES
THE TIMELINESS THE PUBLIC HAS A
BETTER SENSE OF WHERE THE BIG
DOLLARS ARE MOVING- AT THOSE
CRITICAL PEAK. AT TIMES IN THE
LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR AND I WAS
FRUSTRATED BY THAT JUST SORT OF
STANDARD QUARTERLY REPORTING
THAT DIDN'T SINK WITH THE
NATURE. OF THE PEAK TIMES IN
THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS AT
THE VET HAS ALREADY HELPED MOVE
THE BILL. GOT MOTION. FAMOUS
MULLIN ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. LOOKING FOR A
SECOND GOT COUPLE SECONDS AND A
THIRD. CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YEAH APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION- YOU
KNOW I THINK WE ALL KNOW WE'RE
TRYING TO GET AT IMPROVING THE
SYSTEM CREATES MORE
TRANSPARENCY FOR US FOR MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC. QUITE FRANKLY FOR
THE MEMBERS THE LOBBYING CORD
TO SOMETIMES YOU KNOW. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE INCREDIBLY
ABOVE BOARD AND JUST TRYING TO
DO THEIR JOBS- WITH HONOR- AND
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT IT'S ABOUT PROVIDING
TRANSPARENCY IS WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE
END. I WANT ALL THESE VOTES ARE
HAPPENING SO QUICKLY AND SO
MUCH MONEY'S MOVING AROUND AND
SO MANY MESSAGES ARE ARE
SKATING AROUND. WE ALL DESERVES
TO HAVE A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION AS TO AS TO WHAT'S
BEHIND THAT- THOSE EFFORTS AND
SO ON BUT I AM ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND WITH
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
WITH OUR FRIENDS- YOU KNOW
REPRESENTED BY DOMINIC CAT- TO
ENSURE THAT THIS IS DONE IN A
WAY THAT PROVIDES US WITH THE
TRANSPARENCY. THAT WE ALL ARE
LOOKING FOR- WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME I'M NOT CREATING
UNNECESSARY EXTRANEOUS EXTRA
PAPERWORK IT DOESN'T PROVIDE US
WITH THAT THAT THAT- YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY. SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
ALLOW ME TO WORK FURTHER ON
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU CENTER AND
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS HARD WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND
ON HIS EFFORTS TO ADDRESS. THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS OF
THE OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL
IMPROVING LOBBYING DISCLOSURE
ESPECIALLY DURING THE END OF
THE LEGISLATIVE ESSION WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT THERE IS MORE
TIMELY AND MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION ABOUT EFFORTS TO
INFLUENCE LEGISLATION BUT BUT
AS WE SAW TODAY THERE'S STILL
SOME DETAILS THAT NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT WE WILL WE WERE ABLE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE BIG.
KIND ITEMS IN IN THE COMMITTEE-
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS PLEDGE
TO WORK WITH ME AND COMMITTEE
STAFF- YOU KNOW IT DID IT JUST
INTO THE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
AROUND THE BILL ON SOME OF THE
FINE TUNING SOME OF THE DETAILS
OF THAT THAT MIGHT COME UP- AND
KEEPING US IN THE LOOP AS AS
THAT MOVES FORWARD- BUT HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL WITHIN
MOMENTS OF. IN THE CA ALICE.
MANAGER CAN JUST THE MY
PROPOSAL DOES WANT TO THANK YOU
COMMITTEE STAFF. I AND ALSO
MCKINLEY ON MY STAFF WHO JUST
WORKED REALLY HARD OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS TO GET THIS
TO THE TO. TO A- TO A PLACE FOR
WORK. WEARING IN GREATER
CONCORD SHE'S SHE'S BEEN
WORKING QUIETLY HARD I JUST
WANNA I WANT TO PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGE HER HARD WORK
AGREED TO UNDER PERCENT.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL VOTE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I SAY ARE TERRIBLE TO
SEE OUR CHAU NOT VOTING
BENNETT. BENNETT HI LO. LO I
MAYES. MAYES I MULLIN. MULLIN I
BLANCA RUBIO. BLANCA RUBIO I.
TWO THREE FOUR THAT BILLS OUT.
OF WITH SIX AYE VOTES- IT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MOVE ON YOUR NEXT
BILL. SB SEVEN FIFTY TWO SIR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR YOUR SUPPORT ON THAT
LAST BILL ALL RIGHT LET'S NOT
TALK ABOUT SB SEVEN FIFTY TWO.
I'M I WANT TO ONCE AGAIN THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFFERS FOR A
HARD WORK ON THIS MEASURE AND I
WANT EXCEPT THE MOMENTS THAT
ARE SUGGESTED ANNOUNCES THAT
HELP TO MAINTAIN DISCLOSE ACT
REGULATORY. CONSISTENCY SO IN
THE LAST FEW ELECTION CYCLES WE
SEE NEW TACTICS ARE USED TO
AVOID TRANSPARENCY BY
CIRCUMVENTING CURRENT. CAMPAIGN
FUNDING DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS. SO FORMATTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR POLITICAL TV
ADS ALLOW AD FUNDERS TO MAKE
TAXED I'M CLEAR TO VIEWERS AND
ONLINE GRAPHIC ADS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO DISPLAY ANY TOP.
CONTRIBUTORS ASSEMBLY TITIAN
SIGNATURE GATHERS HAVE NOT BEEN
SHOWING UP SHOWING VOTERS THE
LIST OF TOP. FUNDERS OF THE
PETITION CAMPAIGN AS REQUIRED
BY LAW. AND POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEES HAVE UTILIZED A
LOOPHOLE TO HIDE THEIR TOP
FUNDERS AND LOCAL LEGISLATIVE
RACES WITH MANY CONTRIBUTIONS
COMING JUST. IN UNDER FIVE
FIFTY THOUSAND WHICH IS WHERE
WE ACTUALLY SEEN SEVERAL FORTY
NINE NINE NINE NINE.
CONTRIBUTIONS OF JUST COME IN
RIGHT UNDER THE- THE THRESHOLD
SO THIS IS A COURSE YOU KNOW I
PRETTY. CLEAR TTEMPT TO AVOID
DISCLOSURE UNDER THE CURRENT IS
CLOSE ACT THRESHOLD SO- THIS
BILL UPDATES FORMATTING
REQUIREMENTS ON TV AND ONLINE
ADVERTISEMENTS TO MAKE
DISCLOSURE STATEMENTS MORE
EASILY RATHER READABLE. IT
LOWERS THE THRESHOLD TO BE
CONSIDERED A TOP CONTRIBUTOR
AND LOCAL LEGISLATIVE AND FORTY
CAUSATION RACES TO TIGHTEN UP
THE CONTRIBUTION LOOPHOLE. IT
ALSO ADDS A- A TOP FUNDER
DISCLOSURE STATEMENT INTO EACH
PETITION SIGNATURE BOX OF
VOTERS CAN OR MERELY A WHERE
THE INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE TO
THEM. I'M IN THE BILL INCLUDES
UPDATES THE TEXT MESAGE
DISCLOSURE PROVIDING OPTIONS
FOR MORE NATURAL CONVERSATION
OVERTAXED- SO THIS BILL WILL
BRING WE'VE WE'VE DONE A RAFT
OF DISCLOSURE BILLS OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS IN A NUMBER OF
YOU HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THOSE
EFFORTS. WE'RE WE'RE JUST WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE LEARNING IN REAL
TIME FROM THE- THE WAYS THAT AT
TO MAKE TO MAKE THESE VERY
DISCLOSURE BILLS A LITTLE
STRONGER LITTLE BETTER AND IN
SOME RESPECTS MORE SMOOT- BUT
IN THE END OF THE DAY THIS BILL
IS ALL ABOUT PROVIDING- NEED
CLARITY TO OUR POLITICAL
PROCESS PROVIDING VOTERS WITH
VITAL INFORMATION TO MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS SO. WITH
THAT WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
REMOTELY THIS MORNING WE HAVE
TRAVELING WITH COMPANY CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN TO MARK POWERS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION. GREAT
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN LET'S
MOVE ON A PRIMER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT A REMINDER PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES. TO TESTIFY. AND
FIRST UP IS MISTER JOHN LANG.
HI GOOD MORNING SIR BERMAN THE
MEMBERS- I'M TERRIFYING
PRESENTLY CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN- WERE PROUD TO
SPONSOR SB SEVEN FIFTY TWO AND
ARE GRATEFUL TO CENTER ALLEN
FOR OFFERING IT AND ITS
CONTINUED LONG TIME LEADERSHIPIN TRANSPARENCY AND DISCLOSURE
AND ALSO THIS. THIS COMMITTEE
OF COURSE. AND TO THE CHAIR IN
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL- WE DUMP
THIS BILL THE DISCLOSURE
CLARITY ACT BECAUSE THE
CLARIFIES US. FROM REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE THE TOP
FUNDERS MORE CLEAR. BUT REALLY
COULD BE CALLED THE STOP ABUSES
OF THE DISCLOSE ACT ACT- HAS
BEEN AROUND DISTRICT. DESCRIBED
BY PART OF MAJORITY THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO SHOW
VOTERS A TOP FUNDERS THE BALLOT
MEASURE INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURE
ADS. IN THE PAST GENERALITAT
DITION DISPOSED ACTIVE P. FORTY
SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TO SHOW VOTERS TOP UNDER
CIRCULATING AND MISTER
PREFERENCE. AND. RECALL
PETITIONS. THE BILL TO WORK
REALLY WELL WE TAKE A- AND WE
ALL SEEN THE SCHOOL. COULD THE
TOP. ON TV- RADIO AT THAT
CETERA UP BUT AS SOON AROUND
DESCRIBED WE HAVE SEEN A MAJOR
ABUSES UP THEIR INTENT TO MAKE
IT HARDER FOR VOTERS TO SEE THE
POP UNDERS ON ON TV ESPECIALLY.
ON ONLINE IMAGE ADS WHERE THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE TO SHO TOP
UNDER RIGHT NOW AT AT. ALL
UNLIKE EVERY OTHER COUNTRY OUT.
IN LOCAL LEGISLATIVE RACES BUT
THAT FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR WILL
PULL THEM BY MISTER SIGNATURE
GATHERERS- I'M SO HAPPY TO
FIFTY TWO IT UP THE ADDRESS OF
THESE ABUSES WE SEEN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS WE THINK A VERY
REASONABLE FASHION- WE ALSO
WORK WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES THE AUTHOR OF THE
TEXT MESSAGE DISCOTEK FROM
LAST. SESSION TO COME UP WITH A
TO BE CLEAN UP CLARIFICATION.
TO MAKE THAT THE WORDING MORE
NATURALISTIC- WE BELIEVE THESE
THESE COMMONSENSE CHANGES
SHOULD ADDRESS ALL THE PIECES
THAT WE'VE BEN SEEING. SO
PEOPLE CAN ALWAYS CLEARLY THINK
THE TOP FUNDERS OF ABOUT
MEASURING HOW E. F. AS
INTENDED- AND HOPEFULLY THIS
BILL PASSED THE WE WON'T BE TO
MAKE. ANY FOR MANY CHANGES TO
THE SCHOOLS ARE SCHOOLS FOR
AWHILE THOUGH I'M SURE. PEOPLE
FIND CLEVER WAYS EVENTUALLY ARE
AROUND EVEN THE IS BUT PEOPLE
EXPECT ME TO LUNCH RIGHT NOW.
THANKS AGAIN AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER LANG
AND EXCEPT WE HAVE MISTER
POWERS. OF THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU MISTER TERM MEMBER. THIS IS
MARK POWERS IN THE- BUT-
RESEARCH. WE THE RADIO TV.
SERVING YOUR TO. ARE HOW WE
WORK MANY YEARS WOULD TRENTON
THE CLEAN MONEY ORGANIZATION TO
ENSURE THE POLITICAL AD
DISCLOSURES ACROSS MEDIA
PLATFORMS ARE. PERSONAL CARE
BUT THE DISCLOSURE ITSELF DOES
NOT PROVIDE A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE FOR ONE MEDIUM OVER
ANOTHER SECONDLY CONSISTENT.
WITH VOTERS CAN EXPECT TO SEE
THE SAME INFORMATION ACROSS ALL
MEDIA PLATFORMS. SO WE SUPPORT
THE IDEA IN THIS BILL TO LOWER
THE THRESHOLD FOR TOP FUNDERS
FOR LOCAL RACES. SO VIEWERS AND
LISTENERS DON'T WONDER WHY SOME
BALLOT MEASURE AT CHAU TOP
FUNDERS AND SOME DON'T. AND THE
THIRD THING WE ALWAYS
CONCENTRATE ON IT SIMPLICITY.
THAT DISCLOSURES ARE SHORT AS
POSSIBLE AND EASY TO
UNDERSTAND. WE BELIEVE THAT
DISCLOSURE CHANGES PROPOSED FOR
TV ADS IN THIS BILL ARE
REASONABLE. AND SHOULD ALLOW
VOTERS TO QUICKLY AND EASILY
READ TOP CONCERTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT UP WE'LL MOVE ON A PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHICH
WE DON'T HAVE ANY THEREFORE
WILL MOVE INTO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB SEVEN FIFTY
TWO AS A REMINDER THE PUBLIC
WHAT FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL
TIME FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THE NAME OF THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY. IN THE
POSITION ON THE BILL WILL
START- IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO PROVIDE
THEIR POSITION. ON S. B. SEVEN
FIFTY TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD
MISTER CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TERRY BROWN ON BEHALF
OF EFIA YOU CALIFORNIA. I
APOLOGIZE OUR LETTER DID MAKE
IT IN TIME FOR THE ANALYSIS-
BUT IT IS IN THE PORTAL AND IN
THE- SENATORS OFFICE- WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL PRINCIPALLY BECAUSE-
REDUCING THAT THRESHOLD FOR
ANYBODY WHO'S NOT PART OF THE
PRIMARY COMMITTEE. IN OTHER
WORDS JUST A GENERAL COMMITTEE
OR PAC. IDENTIFIES PEOPLE WHO
MAY NOT AGREE WITH THE POSITION
TAKEN. AND SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
TO AN ISSUE. ALSO- SOME OF
THESE MEASURES FOR THINGS THAT
WERE DISCUSSED AS RECOGNIZED IN
THE ANALYSIS THIS IS THE FIFTH
BILL IN FOUR YEARS IN THE
SUBJECT AREA. EACH OF THEM HAVE
BEEN NEGOTIATED AD NAUSEAM- I'D
LOVE NEVER TO TALK ABOUT THIS
AGAIN. BUT WE DO IT ALL THE
TIME AND VIRTUALLY EVERYONE OF
THESE. HIGHER FOR CATIONS WITH
NEGOTIATED REJECTED IN PRIOR
VERSIONS OF THIS BILL YEAH
WE'RE COMING BACK FOR ANOTHER
BITE AT THE APPLE. AND YOU KNOW
WE DON'T THINK THAT'S FAIR
WITHOUT HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS UNLIKE THE PRIOR
BILL WE HAVE NOT HAD DIRECT
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE OFFICE
OFFICE. WORD THE SPONSORS ON
THIS BILL FOR THAT REASON WE
REMAIN OPPOSED THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
THINK THAT AS THE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION- GOING ON
TO ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
AND SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. I
DON'T SEE ANY IN THE ROOM
TODAY- SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION DON'T
SEE ANYBODY THE MORE TESTIMONY
STATION. LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO PROVIDE THEIR
POSITION ON S. B. SEVEN FIFTY
TWO MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION. TO SB SEVEN
FIFTY TWO. REMINDER TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ABOUT SB
SEVEN FIVE TWO PARK PRESS ONE.
ON YOUR PHONE AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO WORK FIRST COMMENT
FROM LINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING DOOR ROSE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ASKED
ABOUT A LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MANCINA REPRESENTING
THEM MANY CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN VOLUNTEERS WHO
WOULD HAVE CALLED IN A
PRODUCTIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL- FUNNELING
EVERYONE THROUGH YOU MS NAFF-
ANY BILL- ANYBODY ELSE.
BORDERLINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HEY THIS IS EVAN
MAINTAIN WITH BLANKETS FOR
PROGRESS OUR MEMBERS ARE MAJOR
FUNDERS THAT ALEXION AND ADD
MANY WHO WOULD BE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE BILL WE HAVE A
PRIORITY SUPPORT POSITION ON IT
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT
TRANSPARENCY IS VITAL TO A
HEALTHY DEMOCRACY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. RYAN SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JENNIFER TANNER ON BEHALF OF
THE VISIBLE CALIFORNIA GREEN
TEAM AND STILL COUNTY FIFTY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GROWING TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS SARAH
CATHERINE CARPIO ON BEHALF OF
COURAGE CALIFORNIA AND
INITIATE. TAXPAYERS TO BE
ARGUED A PASS AT SEVEN FIFTY
TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN JONATHAN ABOUT
THIS TIME EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE WORKING
STRONG SUPPORT SB SEVEN FIVE
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FIND SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK
THAT IS ME HI THIS IS STEPHANIE
BROWN I AM REPRESENTING OCI
ORCHARD CITY INDIVISIBLE AND
TOGETHER WE WILL INDIVISIBLE
LEFT PRODUCT AND URGING. YOU TO
PLEASE PASS THE SEVEN FIFTY TWO
AM WHERE YOU ARE AND DISTRICT
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL GOOD CARE OF ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SLANG THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WARNING
CAN WE SHOP BETTER DIRECTOR NO
NEED MONEY OUT VOTERS AND ALSO-
I'M ON THE L. A. C. D. HE-
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE
AND BOTH OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
AREN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF THE S.
B. SEVEN FIFTY K. GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NINE THIRTY
SEVEN LINE IS OPEN. THIS
COMMITTEE HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE PEOPLE IT'S ALL ABOUT
SPECIAL IN. WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS YES I WAS WONDERING
THANK YOU SO. NO MORE ALL RIGHT
WILL BRING ABOUT A COLLEAGUES
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MOTIONS OR SECONDS- BRING IT
BACK. DO YOU SEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OR MOTIONS ARE
SECONDS I DON'T GOT A MOTION.
GOT A SECOND. DON'T SEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMES IN IT IS A
QUICK QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR-
IN THIS IS KIND OF REFERENCED
IN IN SOME COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE- IN IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THE A BIT THAT AS YOU KNOW
TWO YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED AB TWO A ONE. BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES WHICH
CHANGED THE DISCLOSURES THAT
ARE REQUIRED ON POLITICAL TEXT
MESSAGES THE FINAL VERSION OF
THAT BILL WAS THE PRODUCT OF
EXTENSIVE NEGOTIATIONS OVER THE
BILL LANGUAGE BETWEEN MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS- AND
JUST WANT TO. CHECK AND SEE YOU
KNOW THIS BILL CONTAINS A
PROVISION THAT WOULD MODIFY.
THE LANGUAGE OF AB TWO OH ONE
HAVE THERE BEEN DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN THE AB TWO OH ONE
TO GO SHE ASIANS- AND IF SO
WHAT WAS THEIR RESPONSE TO THE
CHANGES PROPOSED BY THE BILL I
UNDERSTAND I'VE BEEN
CONVERSATIONS WITH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES IS OFFICE
SPACE BUT CHECKING TO SEE IF
THERE BEEN CONVERSES WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS YOU KNOW SO I'M
SORRY YOUR CERVANTES IS THE
ASSEMBLY PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF
THIS OF THIS BILL I'M TO BE
HONEST I IN AYE. AYE WE WITH
THIS PASS A THREE THIRTY FIVE
ZERO VOTE IN THE SENATE THERE
IS LITTLE YOU. KNOW REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AS OF- EITHER IN THE
SENATE OR- FOR- AS OF- YOU KNOW
YOUR OWN PUBLICATION OF YOUR
ANALYSIS. HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE SO I AM I AM VERY
PLEASED TO SIT DOWN WITH TERRY
AND TALK SHOP- BE MAKE SURE
THAT YEAH WE CAN WORK THROUGH
WHATEVER ISSUES THAT WE- NEED
TO. ADD TO GET TO GOOD PLACE ON
THIS BILL BUT I WAS NOT AWARE
LITERALLY UNTIL JUST NOW- THAT-
DID THEIR WORK THAT THEY WERE
FOLKS HAD CHALLENGES WITH THE
BILL SO- J. THAT OPEN AS I
BELIEVE THIS IS. IN REFERENCE
TO A AMENDMENTS ARE MADE THE
LAST COUPLE WEEKS SO AS TO NOT
NECESSARILY HANGS AROUND THE
BILL ON THE SENATE SIDE- SO BUT
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOU KNOW
WILLINGNESS TO. TO HAVE TO
CONVENE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
THAT'S- THAT'S ALL I ASK. I'M
HAPPY TO DO AND HAPPY TO DO IT
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE WITH
THE COMMITTEE. THANKS AND
APPRECIATE IT- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. YEAH AND WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING CERTAINLY ASK TO
ALLOW US TO MOVE FORWARD. IF
ANY OF THE MEMBERS WANT TO HELP
ENGAGE IN THAT DISCUSSION WITH
THEM I CA WHEN OTHERS HAPPY TO
HAVE TO INCLUDE YOU IN THAT
DISCUSSION BUT- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STEPS IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS TO HELP VOTERS MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS. BY
REQUIRING THAT VOTERS BE
PROVIDED WITH INFORMATION ABOUT
THE TOP FUNDERS OF POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENTS AND BALLOT
MEASURE. CAMPAIGNS THIS BILL
REFINES THOSE RULES TO HELP
ENSURE THAT THE INFORMATION
ABOUT THOSE MAJOR FUNDERS IS
CONVEYED. IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
TO VOTERS. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED. AMENDMENTS
AND DEFERRED YEAH THE
CONVERSATION WE JUST HAD A
AROUND YEAH MAKING SURE THAT.
PRIOR STAKEHOLDERS ARE ENGAGED
IN ANY AMENDMENTS THAT THAT
MIGHT AMEND OR ALTER- YOU KNOW.
PRIOR TO DISCUSSIONS AND
AGREEMENTS THAT WERE REACHED-
ASSUMING THIS BILL WITH OTHER
COMMITTEE TODAY- YET WE ARE TO
TALK ABOUT THAT THAT BEING
SAID. HAPPY TO RECOMMEND
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL- WITH THE
AMENDMENTS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I SAY OCTOBER ZERO TWO
IS NOT VOTING BANDIT. BANDIT I
LO. LO I'M MAYES. MAYES I
MULLIN. MULLIN I BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO HI. THAT BILL IS
OUT WITH SIX VOTES
CONGRATULATIONS CENTER. DID YOU
EVER THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND SOON WE HAVE OUR- BUT LEAST
BILL. OF THIS MORNING'S AGENDA-
HEARING- I NUMBER SIX. SB SIX
EIGHTY SIX A VERY GOOD BILL. BY
CENTER GLAZER. I DON'T WANNA.
DON'T WANNA YOU KNOW KINDA.
SWAY THINGS TOO MUCH IT IS A
VERY GOOD BILL I WAS COMMENTING
CENTER GLAZER GOT EMOTION GOT A
SECOND. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN LET ME THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- LEADERSHIP I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA AND FOR YOUR STAFF FOR
THEIR GOOD WORK AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT THIS BILL HAS HAD ONE
CHEN A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FROM
WHEN IT WAS LAST WEEK REVIEWED
BY THIS COMMITTEE WE WORK WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND HAPPY TO SAY THAT
THE CHAMBER HAS REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND THE
FORM IN WHICH WILL BRING IT TO
YOU TODAY- BUT- SIX EIGHT SIX
SIX TO PROVIDE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND DISCLOSURE FOR
LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANIES.
THAT MAKE POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS THESE L. C.'S
HAVE LIMITED EXISTING PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS AND THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT AND OTHER
EXISTING LAWS. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN A FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
EXAMINATION OF LLCS FOUND THAT.
IT WAS RELATIVELY EASY TO FIND
INFORMATION ABOUT AN L. L.
C.'S. TYPE OF BUSINESS IT'S
ADDRESS. ITS AGING FOR SERVICES
A PROCESS. HOWEVER IT WAS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT AND MANY
TIMES IMPOSSIBLE TO IDENTIFY IN
L. L. C.'S OWNER. OR THE TRUE
SOURCE OF FUNDS. OF AN LLC'S
POLITICAL EXPENDITURE. SB SIX
EIGHT SIX SIX TO PROVIDE THE
PUBLIC WITH THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION L. L. C. THAT MAKE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
SPECIFICALLY SIX EIGHT SIX
REQUIRES LLC'S TO SUBMIT TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE UPON
QUALIFYING AS A COMMITTEE A
LIST OF MEMBERS WHO EITHER HAVE
A MEMBERSHIP INTEREST IN THE
LLC OF AT LEAST TEN PERCENT. OR
MADE A CUMULATIVE CAPITAL
CONTRIBUTION OF AT LEAST TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE L. L.
C. AND THAT TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR
THRESHOLD IS SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
THAT WAS MADE. FROM THE BILL
THAT YOU LAST HEARD I
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE NOW WHO'S
TRYING TO INFLUENCE OUR
POLITICAL PROCESS THIS BILL IS
A SIMPLE YET MEANINGFUL
APPROACH TO PROVIDE CLARITY
REGARDING POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS AND AIMS TO
DISCLOSE THE TRUE SOURCE OF
FUNDS USED BY THE L. L. FEES.
ARE THE BILL SPONSORED BY THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION ON THE PHONE LINES
THREE SHERMAN AT YOUR
DISCRETION TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IS LINDSEY MCCONNELL
WITH THE FCC WITHOUT A WITH
ROUGHLY ASTRONAUT THANK YOU
SENATOR SO LET'S MOVE TO
PREMIER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
MS MCCONNELL IF YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE- YOU START WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. HERE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LINDSAY MCCONNELL AND
I'M LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL FOR THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION. FIFTY FIFTIETH THE
STATE COMMISSION THAT
ADMINISTERS AND ENFORCES THE
POLITICAL PERFORMANCE WHICH
REGULATE CAMPAIGN FINANCING
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST. LOBBYING
AND GOVERNMENTAL ETHICS.
COMMISSION IS PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL. SB
SIXTY SIX SPENT LIKE ON A DARK
AREA THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ALMOST NO TOOLS ELIMINATE. OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS FIFTY
FIFTY HAVE FOUND INCREASING
INSTANCES OF THESE BEING USED.
TO USUALLY NO WAY FOR THE
PUBLIC TO IDENTIFY THE
INDIVIDUALS BEHIND THE
CONTRIBUTION. GOAL BUT STILL
PROTECT THE DARK MONEY PROBLEM
BY SHEDDING LIGHT ON THE TRUE
SOURCE OF THESE CONTRIBUTIONS
ARE REQUIRING DISCLOSURE OF
CERTAIN MEMBERS OF THE L. L. C.
OR OTHER WORDS DISCLOSURE OF
WHO HAS FUNDED THE L. B. THE
FIRST CLOSURE WOULD BE REQUIRED
ONLY IF THE L. L. C. REACHES A
THRESHOLD LEVEL OF POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES THAT WERE ALREADY
UNDER CURRENT LAW. SUBJECT THE
L. L. C. TO REGULATION UNDER
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT AT THE
COMMITTEE OR COMMITTEE FONT
THERE. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
DISCLOSURE OF NOT EVERY MEMBER
OF THE L. I'LL SEE THAT RATHER
ONLY THOSE WHO HAVE A 10% OR
GREATER MEMBERSHIP INTEREST OR
HAVE REACHED A THRESHOLD LEVEL
OF NIELSEN CAPITAL CONTRIBUTION
TO THE L. L. C. WITHIN A
CERTAIN PERIOD. THE BILL HAS
RECENTLY AMENDED TO REVISE THE
THRESHOLDS AND THE COMMISSION
HAS NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FORMALLY WEIGH IN ON THE
AMENDMENT. I RECEIVED POSITIVE
FEEDBACK FROM THE COMMISSIONERS
ABOUT THESE AMENDMENTS AT
PREVIOUS PUBLIC MISSION MEETING
AND THE CHAIR OF THE COMMISSION
HAS EXPRESSED TO ME HIS SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL AS AMENDED AND HAS
INDICATED THAT HE WILL
RECOMMEND CONTINUED SUPPORT. TO
THE COMMISSION AFTER MEETING IN
TWO WEEKS. BAXLEY'S A THE BILL
AFTER MAY. INTO TO THE-
INCREASED. IN THIS AREA. AND
FAIRLY BAD. THE IMMENSE BENEFIT
TO THE PUBLIC. AGAINST THE
MINIMAL BURDEN OF SUBMITTING AN
ADDITIONAL FORM. THANK YOU FOR
THE AUTHOR AND CO AUTHORS FOR
TAKING UP THIS IMPORTANT
SUBJECT. I THINK YOU JUST MAYBE
FOR HEARING THE BILL TODAY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THEIR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WILL
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PRIMER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PRIMER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO- ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WHO WISH
TO- TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB SIX EIGHTY
SIX AS A REMINDER THE PUBLIC
WHAT FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL
TIME FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED WRITING
THEIR NAME THE ORGANIZATION OF
THE REPRESENT IF ANY. AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL WILL STAR
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS OR
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO JUST
PROVIDE THE POSITION ON S. B.
SIX EIGHTY SIX. SEEING NONE.
LOOK OVER TO THE- REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION THERE'S
NOBODY THERE SO WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE A POSITION. ON SB
SIX EIGHTY SIX MODERATOR TO
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION. SB
SIX EIGHTY SIX. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT BEST
THREE SIX EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE NO
TELEPHONE AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST TIME- COME FROM A
LANDLINE NUMBER FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING DANDORA
ROSALIE GOVERNMENT GO TO
CALIFORNIA IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT BRING IT BACK
TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OR MOTIONS OR
SECONDS. GOT A MOTION. WE
ALREADY HAVE A MOTION AS I DO
IT FOR THIS ONE THINGS BUT
THINGS HAPPEN FAST IN THIS IN
THIS COMMITTEE- GOT A MOTION
GOT A SECOND ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COLLEAGUES
SEEING NONE CENTER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MEMBERS- ONE FACTOID TO
CLOSE- ALMOST TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED PEOPLE. DONATED WERE
MAJOR DONORS IN THE LAST A-
YEAR. UP ALMOST 10% OF THE MORE
LLCS THIS IS NOT A LITTLE
ISSUES TEN PERCENT. L. L. C. SO
WE'RE TRYING TO DO OUR BEST
WORK HERE TO PROVIDE A- AN
IMPORTANT LEVEL OF DISCLOSURE
WITHOUT RESPECT. WAY
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU TO
SENATOR. IF ANY COLLEAGUES ARE
HAVING DEJA VU- IT'S BECAUSE I
PRESENTED A VERY SIMILAR BILL
COUPLE MONTHS AGO IF YOU'RE NOT
HAVING DAYS OFF- YOU'RE NOT
PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE COMMITTEE- I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR- WHO
HAVE BEEN. HAPPY TO WORKING
TOGETHER WITH ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I'M HAPPY TO
RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE ON THE
BILL TODAY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE HELLO. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN HI BERMAN I SEE ARTURO
SEE ALSO KNOW BENNETT. BENNETT
I LOW. LOW ON MAYES. MAYES AYE
MULLIN. MULLIN I RUBIO. BLANCA
RUBIO I. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
SIX TO ONE VOTE- RELATION
CENTER PROJECT LET'S- THE- WHAT
ADDITIONAL OR LIKE COLLEAGUES
OUT ON TO BILLS THEY MIGHT'VE
MISSED. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RUN THROUGH THE AGENDA. ON SB
FIVE OH THREE BECKER THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE THE MOTION WAS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW. LOW I
MULLIN. MULLIN I. ADAM FOR SB
FIVE OH FOR BECKER- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY THE
CHAIR VOTING I LO LO I HAVE
MULLIN. HI MULLIN I. ADAM SEVEN
S. B. SEVEN ONE FOUR CABALLERO-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIRS HOLDEN I ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW. LOW IS NOT VOTING MULLIN.
HI MULLIN I. THAT'S EVERYTHING
THANK RATE THANK YOU EVERYBODY
MUCH THANK YOU EVERYBODY VERY
MUCH THANK YOU STAFF THE
SERGEANTS AND THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.